0 57
175.000 menschen
die aus der ukraine geflohen sind das
nach deutschland gekommen und hier
registriert worden die zahl liegt
wahrscheinlich deutlich höher denn im
regelfall findet ihr an der grenze keine
festen grenzkontrollen stadt also es
geht um die lage der flüchtlinge um die
versorgung um die unterbringung und die
registrierung wir hören erste rednerin
andrea lindholz
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen in der ukraine
mitten in europa herrscht krieg putins
bomben haben die größte flüchtlingskrise
in europa seit dem zweiten weltkrieg
ausgelöst über drei millionen menschen
befinden sich bereits aus der ukraine
auf der flucht heute morgen hat uns der
ukrainische präsident
zugeschaltet aus dem kriegsgebiet noch
einmal eindringlich gebeten auf allen
ebenen zu helfen am sonntag konnte ich
mit mir konnte ich mir mit kollegen an
der polnisch ukrainischen grenze selbst
ein bild von der note machen und es hat
mich zutiefst
erschüttert es waren so viele
vor allem frauen kinder
jugendliche alte frauen die schutz
suchen in polen in deutschland in europa
ihre männer und ihre söhne bleiben
zurück in der heimat
um mit ihrem leben die heimat zu
verteidigen
die erschöpfung die verzweiflung den mut
der frauen zu sehen die vielen kinder
das kann ich auch heute noch kaum in
worte fassen es hat mich sehr berührt
und
für uns für die union und für mich
selbst ist vollkommen klar wir müssen
wir müssen mit aller kraft helfen
in der dunkelheit gibt es immer auch
helle hoffnungsschimmer und was wir auch
erlebt haben ist die große
hilfsbereitschaft und die professionelle
organisation unserer polnischen nachbarn
sie haben bereits über 15 millionen
menschen aufgenommen polen hat ein
großes herz und einen kühlen kopf und
auch bei uns hier in deutschland haben
die menschen ein großes herz zur
wahrheit gehört aber auch ohne die
vielen ehrenamtlichen helfer und
engagierten kommunalpolitiker
wäre unser staat aufgeschmissen wir
sollten ihnen allen heute ausdrücklich
danken und ihnen versichern dass das
engagement des bundes sie nachhaltig
unterstützen muss und dass wir auch
dafür sorge tragen müssen dass unser
ehrenamt nicht überfordert wird
um hilfe zu ermöglichen braucht es auch
staatliche ordnung und kontrolle und das
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ist der
kühle kopf die bundesregierung hat eine
schutzpflicht den vielen frauen kindern
und jugendlichen die aus dem krieg
fliehen die schutz suchen und diese
schutzpflicht hat sie bis jetzt nicht
ausreichend erfüllt bei der
registrierung bei der ankunft an den
bahnhöfen bei der erstaufnahme unter und
der unterbringung herrscht teilweise
chaos und damit nicht genug seit wochen
warnen die polizeigewerkschaften vor
skrupellosen kriminellen die versuchs-
und frauen und mädchen aus der ukraine
in ihre gewalt zu bekommen nur wenige
hundert meter von hier entfernt
am berliner hauptbahnhof gibt es diese
übergriffe die bundespolizei warnt dort
auf schildern junge frauen und
unbegleitete minderjährige vor
auffälligen
übernachtungsangeboten die warnungen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die sind
richtig aber das darf nicht alles sein
frauen kinder jugendliche die vor krieg
fliegen sie brauchen kein laisser-faire
sie brauchen schutz und ordnende
staatliche strukturen und wenn auch nur
eine ukrainische frau die jetzt bei uns
schutz sucht in der zwangsprostitution
landet oder auch nur ein unbegleiteter
minderjähriger in not gerät weil unser
staat schlecht organisiert ist oder weil
er zu langsam agiert dann lässt sich das
mit nichts wiedergutmachen und
deshalb fordern wir eine sofortige
straffung für frauen und für kinder
zieht die zu uns kommen das bedeutet
eine systematische registrierung direkt
nach der einreise damit wir wissen wer
zu uns kommt wer bleiben wird und um wen
wir uns kümmern müssen darauf zu hoffen
dass die frauen selbst den weg zu einer
aufnahmeeinrichtung oder der
ausländerbehörde finden das ist kein
konzept es braucht schutzzonen an
bahnhöfen in denen professionelle
hilfsorganisationen die frauen und
kinder in empfang nehmen sie versorgen
und in zentral geschützte
erstaufnahmeeinrichtungen weiterleiten
es ist kein zustand dass sich irgendwer
am berliner hauptbahnhof an anderen
bahnhöfen befindet und die frauen
mitnehmen kann und
und es braucht einen krisenstab in dem
bund länder und kommunen dauerhaft über
verteilung versorgung und alle weiteren
fragen sich austauschen frau ministerin
feser hat diesen krisenstab die grünen
haben ein krisen gipfel gefordert ein
flüchtlings gipfel gefordert dieser
woche in der regierungsbefragung vom
tisch gefegt das bräuchte es nicht aber
ich glaube auch die grünen haben zweifel
am krisenmanagement sonst hätten sie
diesen flüchtlings gipfel nicht
gefordert und liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der ampel sie sind in der
regierung handeln sie auch danach frau
feser liebe bundesregierung
realisieren sie endlich den ernst der
lage übernehmen sie verantwortung und
schützen sie die frauen und kinder denn
es werden noch viele verbot vor putins
bomben fliehen
andreas schulz war es für die cdu csu
fraktion eröffnete hier diese aktuelle
stunde die ihre fraktion beantragt hat
und wäre der bundestag hier debattiert
sitzen ja auch bund und länder vertreter
zusammen auch unter anderem um darüber
zu sprechen wie man die menschen die aus
der ukraine geflüchtet sind am besten
versorgt und unterbringen kann und es
gibt eine erste beschlussvorlage die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit dem
boden läuft allerdings noch daraus geht
zumindest hervor dass bund und länder
die registrierung der ukrainische
betriebs flüchtiger beschleunigen wollen
jetzt die beauftragte der
bundesregierung für antirassismus thema
labbadia donau
verehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
ich habe größten respekt vor der ukraine
vor ihrem präsidenten und den
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
sie kämpfen in diesen wochen für ihr
land und ihre demokratie
sie kämpfen für werte die auf unsere
sind es sind universelle werte es geht
um freiheit frieden und das leben putins
krieg ist damit ein angriff auf uns alle
auf unsere werte wir unterstützen die
ukraine mit aller kraft
in diesen wochen für uns oft die worte
putins krieg millionenfaches unsägliches
leid verursacht bei geburtskliniken und
wohnungen zerbombt werden weil frauen
männer und kinder sterben und mir stockt
der atem wenn ich präsident selensky im
bundestag höre wenn ich den mut der
ukraine renault ukrainer sehe wenn ich
bei mir zu hause in schwerin in einer
notunterkunft eine frau aus aktiv wenn
sie mir ihr schicksal erzählt ihre
fluchtgeschichte auch wenn die worte
fielen wir sind nicht sprachlos wir
packen an gemeinsam im schulterschluss
von bund ländern und kommunen gemeinsam
im haupt- und ehrenamt was sind diesen
tagen geleistet wird ist heraustragen
deutschland hilft menschen in größter
not dafür danke ich allen die
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter der
kommunalen verwaltungen dem thw der
bundeswehr den polizeien von bund und
ländern und ich danke ganz besonders den
vielen ehrenamtlichen helferinnen und
helfern deutschland stets zusammen die
menschen legen einfach los tag ein tag
aus dafür gebührt ihm größter respekt
und anerkennung
stand heute sind rund 200.000 menschen
aus der ukraine zu uns geflogen das ist
die größenordnung der hansestadt rostock
und das sind nur die registrierten
tatsächlich sind es weitaus mehr privat
eingereist und untergekommen bei
verwandten und freunden
weil ukrainerinnen und ukrainer ohne
visum einreisen konnten weil wir
niemanden an den grenzen auch halten der
vorbau und granatsplitter und das ist
auch gut so liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
es ist in dieser schlimmen zeit
ermutigend dass europa zusammen stehen
putins krieg ist ein wendepunkt in der
geschichte europas auch für ein europa
entstanden nach dem horror des zweiten
weltkrieges das jetzt wieder stärker
zusammenwächst die idee des gemeinsamen
europas hat sich nicht erledigt ganz im
gegenteil sie ist aktueller denn je ja
die herausforderung bei der aufnahme und
unterbringung ist jetzt riesengroß in
europa aber auch bei uns in deutschland
darum ist es gut dass wir auf allen
ebenen im regelmäßigen austausch sind
bund länder und kommunen die
koordinierung da können sie sich sicher
sein läuft auf hochtouren in diesen
stunden gerade jetzt spricht der
bundeskanzler aber auch die bundes mit
innenministerin mit 1 16
ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidenten der bund koordiniert
die ankünfte von zügen zügen und bussen
ins bundesgebiet die länder melden ihre
kapazitäten zur unterbringung alleine
heute starten zb 147 busse um 9500
plätze mit 909 1500 plätzen die ins
gesamte bundesgebiet fahren in acht
bundesländern um berlin cottbus und
hannover zu entlasten das bamf ist in
allen bundesländern mit amtshilfe aktiv
vor allem bei der registrierung ebenso
helfen bundeswehr und thw und wir
unterstützen bei der verteilung in
deutschland und in der eu das zeigt die
länder und kommunen können sich auf dem
bund verlassen wir unterstützen denn
natürlich wissen wir alle weder berlin
brandenburg oder bayern können das
alleine stemmen ganz deutschland zieht
mit die solidarität liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen ist in diesen tagen
überwältigend und weil ich das jetzt
immer gefragt werde
ja ich bin zuversichtlich und ich weiß
aus meiner erfahrung aus meiner arbeit
in der erstaufnahme dass wir 2022 besser
vorbereitet sind als 2015 wir haben in
der eu mit einem historischen
schulterschluss für schnelle und
unbürokratische aufnahme gesorgt wir
ermöglichen sicheren langfristigen
aufenthalt für alle die aus der ukraine
fliehen dafür hat die bundesregierung
mit dem paragraphen 24 aufenthaltsgesetz
gesorgt damit steht auch der zugang zum
arbeitsmarkt offen der zugang zu
integrationskursen
dass es ein kraftakt das ist integration
von anfang an
zum schluss wir müssen jetzt auch klare
haltung zeigen es gibt keine
geflüchteten erster oder zweiter klasse
es darf niemals um herkunft oder
hautfarbe gehen wir lassen nicht zu wenn
drittstaatsangehörige aus der ukraine an
den grenzen diskriminiert werden polen
um und die slowakei haben klargestellt
dass sie das auch nicht dulden ich nehme
solche meldungen von denen die
außengrenzen
seien wir also gemeinsam weiterhin sehr
wachsam und wie vergessen die
geflüchteten natürlich nicht die bereits
bei uns sind und schutz suchen ob schon
vorher auch aus der ukraine aus syrien
afghanistan eritrea oder dem irak wir
unterteilen nicht in gruppen wir geben
allen menschen sicherheit die schutz
brauchen weil sie menschen sind
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
nein wir sind in diesen tagen nicht
sprachlos wir geben klare antworten auf
putins angriffskrieg in europa in bund
ländern und kommunen gemeinsam stark
fest an der seite der ukraine vielen
dank
[Applaus]
der nächste redner in dieser debatte in
dieser aktuellen stunde zur lage der
ukrainischen flüchtlinge kommt aus der
fdp fraktion gottfried curio ist der
innenpolitische sprecher seiner fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren ja den wirklich vor
krieg fliehen muss geholfen werden
natürlich auch in deutschland wenn die
anrainerstaaten der ukraine überlastet
sind wir wollen hilfsbedürftige
versorgen aber die kapazitäten wer nimmt
denn jetzt denen die kapazitäten weg
nicht nur die paz losen afrikanischen
austauschstudenten die angeblichen
sondern vor allem die hunderttausenden
altfälle von ausreisepflichtigen
asylbewerber die deutschland seit 20.15
mit angabe falscher fluchtgründe
getäuscht haben die diese regierung aber
wie die folge sich weigert abzuschieben
jetzt brauchen wir aber platz für die
wirklich hilfsbedürftigen meine damen
und herren
ja und meine damen und herren von der
union ihnen wird jetzt der spiegel
vorgehalten weil die altlasten an
illegaler migration das system
verstopfen uns ein gebot von parteien
die gerne illegal zu legalen machen
deshalb brauchen wir jetzt den
sofortigen stopp aller sachwidrige
ideologie projekte den stopp der
resettlement aktionen von weitläufigen
familiennachzug wir brauchen eine
abschiebe offensive herr lindner wo
bleibt denn ihr abschiebe beauftragt da
diese schaufenster ankündigung fakt ist
hunderttausende ausreisepflichtige
merkel migranten nehmen die plätze der
heute fliegenden frauen und kinder aus
der ukraine hier in den aufnahmen weg
das ist eine schande meine damen und
herren aber die innenministerin will
sogar alle ausdruck einer anreisenden
aufnehmen auch nicht du keiner die gar
nicht in not sind und nach hause können
die 18 jahre alte ukrainerin in
düsseldorf vergewaltigt von einem iraker
und die koreaner die sich ukrainische
pässe verstand verschafft hatten die
geht zurück nach polen in deutschland
ist es ihr zu unsicher das ist aus
deutschland geworden als ich ist eine
schande meine damen und
woran erkennt man wirkliche flüchtlinge
die sind anders als 2015 meist weiblich
haben ihren passt dabei treten dankbar
auf stadt fordert und sie wollen zurück
in die heimat deshalb braucht es für die
kinder ukrainischen sonder unterricht
statt irgendwelcher integration die
hilfsbereiten bürger aber ärgert die
kontroll verweigerung der wieder bewusst
zugelassener missbrauch der deutschen
hilfsbereitschaft hier in berlin
ankommende züge werden überhaupt nicht
kontrolliert keine
sicherheitsüberprüfung nichts der
vorsitzende der gewerkschaft der
bundespolizei sieht 40 prozent der
ankommenden insgesamt unkontrolliert
deutschland bleibt wieder sperrangelweit
offen für alle arten unerwünschter
trittbrettfahrer von
wirtschaftsmigranten bis terroristen
denken sie an der von der ukraine jetzt
in der ukraine angeforderten syrischen
kämpfer wer täglich 10.000 betten bereit
halten kann der kann auch ordentlich
kontrollieren für die innere sicherheit
wir wollen nicht dass nach syrer und
orts kraft jetzt afrikanischer
austauschstudent zum neuen passepartout
wird wir fordern jeden platz für
ukrainische alte ukrainische frauen und
kinder meine damen und herren das elend
der flüchtlinge das beendet man durch
ein ende der kämpfe da ist russland erst
verantwortlich die verursachung
menschlichen leids zu beenden und laut
jerusalem post fordert der israelische
premier bennett sie lenski auf die
russischen angebote anzunehmen und so
den krieg zu beenden
aber wer de facto dazu beiträgt dass der
krieg immer länger und blutiger wird das
sind auch die die immer mehr waffen
hinein liefern und wer außerhalb der
städte die panzer nicht aufhalten kann
und dann einen guerillakrieg in die
städte trägt auch der erzeugt
flüchtlinge selbstverständlich übergibt
man eine stadt unzerstört und ohne
zivile opfer wenn man militärisch
unterlegen ist selbst wenn man im recht
ist oder wollte irgendwer für den
ernstfall den militärischen häuserkampf
in berlin propagieren angesichts der
unterlegenheit preußens gegenüber dem
aggressor napoleon übergab man berlin
selbstverständlich kampflos ohne
sinnlose tote zerstörungen oder aufruf
zum volkssturm von zivilisten gegen eine
armee das vermeidet große flucht
bewegungen und die option der nato
mitgliedschaft für putin kriegsgrund
hatte man mit einem satz von tisch
nehmen können wie mit dem
deutsch-französischen veto von 2008 wer
wagt es den menschen zu sagen dass ihr
leben und die unversehrtheit ihrer
heimat weniger wert sind als die option
auf brüssel die verbindung mit der nato
es gilt doch fluchtbewegungen immer im
ansatz zu vermeiden sie lenski und polen
wollen die kriegsbeteiligung in den
westen tragen fresken will nato-soldaten
in der ukraine nicht ausschließen
friedrich merz kann sich nato
entscheidungen vorstellen und putin zu
stoppen solche kriegs ausweitung ist
gefährliche zündelei das brauchen wir
nicht schon gar nicht im deutschen namen
lassen sie uns lieber anschließen an
große traditionen deutscher entspannungs
und verständigung politik mal damen und
herren haben und eines sollte klar sein
sobald die kämpfe vorbei sind
unterstützen wir die menschen auf ihrem
weg zurück in die heimat beim
wiederaufbau das ist dann nicht die
ideologie der globalisten die menschen
über den globus schieben wollen sondern
das ist das wirkliche interesse der
geflüchteten es sind menschen die ihre
heimat lieben die ihre heimat bewahren
wollen sie haben unser mitgefühl sie
haben unsere hilfe
die rede des innenpolitischen sprechers
der fdp-fraktion gottfried curio hier
zur lage der ukrainischen
geflüchteten laut bundesinnenministerium
hat deutschland bislang
187.000 ukrainische geflüchtete
aufgenommen allerdings werden nicht alle
geflüchtete auch erfasste denn natürlich
nur die die von der bundespolizei auch
festgestellt werden die zahlen dürften
also deutlich höher liegen so schätzt
man vieles polat spricht jetzt für die
grünen sie
meine damen und herren wir erleben
deutschland und europa stehen vor der
größten flucht bewegungs seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg und
deutschland hat mit dieser
bundesregierung gezeigt dass es jetzt
darauf ankommt
und mehr denn je als in der
vergangenheit die geflüchteten in den
mittelpunkt zu stellen und nicht sich
über zahlen und obergrenzen zu
zerstreiten und ich glaube unsere
koalition kann froh sein dass sie mit
ministerin nancy faeser jemanden in
brüssel hatte der es geschafft die es
geschafft hat europa zu einen und in
kürzester zeit nach 20 jahren erstmalig
die richtlinie zum vorübergehenden
schutz zu aktivieren das war wichtig und
gut so angesichts der wachsenden zahlen
meine damen und herren
und frau staatsministerin riemen aller
bali radovan sie haben es gesagt mit
dieser richtlinie mit aktivierung dieser
richtlinie sind genau die dinge jetzt
möglich die menschen haben zugang zur
gesundheitsversorgung die menschen
bekommen den zugang zum arbeitsmarkt und
sie bekommen unbürokratisch zugang zu
den integrationskursen
hätten wir diese richtlinie schon 2015
und 16 aktivieren können hätten wir uns
einiges erspart was wir erleben mussten
vor allem die menschen die aus syrien
geflohen sind meine damen und herren
für uns bringt ist 90 die grünen ist es
jetzt wichtig dass den worten taten
folgen was heißt das leider und das muss
ich so sagen ist in unserem
aufenthaltsgesetz nach der aktivierung
der richtlinie die rechtsgrundlage der
paragraf 24 den jahr alle mittlerweile
kennen und im gesetzestext heißt es
leider eben nicht dass sie
uneingeschränkt den zugang zum
gesundheitssystem haben oder dass sie
arbeitsmarkt berechtigt sind
nichtsdestotrotz hat ministerin nancy
faeser über den verordnungswege ist
versucht möglich zu machen aber wir sind
uns nicht sicher herr staatsminister
staatssekretär ob wir eine
bundeseinheitliche umsetzung hinbekommen
denn wir wissen in deutschland und in
den bundesländern regieren
unterschiedliche farbkonstellationen
und wenn wir eines wollen dann ist es
dass alle geflüchtete gleich behandelt
werden die aus der ukraine fliehen und
alle wie ich eingangs gesagt hat habe
unbürokratisch zugang zur
versorgungsleistung und zu den
integration maßnahmen bekommen frau
staatsministerin von anfang an
und deshalb wollen wir sicherstellen
dass
die menschen anspruchsberechtigte werden
auf einen integrationskurs und nicht nur
in zulassungs wege und damit abhängig
sind von kapazitäten wir wollen dass sie
erwerbs die erwerbs erlaubnis erhalten
ohne wenn und aber und das unabhängig
davon ob sie drittstaatsangehörige sind
aus der ukraine oder ukrainische
staatsbürgerin meine damen und herren
das zweite thema ist die registrierungs
frage das bundesamt für migration und
flüchtlinge ist angehalten nach der
aktivierung der richtlinie einen
register aufzusetzen und dieses register
wird jetzt erarbeitet das wurde im
innenausschuss auch so vorgetragen
es werden viele viele mitarbeiterin
eingesetzt um so schnell wie möglich die
menschen zu registrieren für uns ist es
aber wichtig das haben wir auch deutlich
gemacht dass die registrierung schon an
den knotenpunkten erfolgt denn das was
wir erleben joachim stamp setzt ja auch
hier dass die geflüchteten die sozusagen
keine familiären bezüge haben klar
wissen müssen in welches bundesland zu
kommen und die bundesländer müssen klar
wissen in welche kommunen sie verteilen
und das geht nur mit der registrierung
an den knotenpunkten nicht erst in den
erstaufnahmeeinrichtung und damit werden
wir dann auch der gewachsenen und
zunehmend dynamischen entwicklung der
fluchtbewegung gerecht meine damen und
herren
und in diesem sinne bei unsere forderung
frau lindholz ein flüchtlings gipfel zu
fordern weil nämlich wir nicht
ignorieren dass in allen
landesparlamenten genau diese diskussion
stattfindet der städtetag und der
landkreistag an uns diese frage
adressiert hat und wir werden uns sicher
sein dass heute auch nach der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
bundeskanzler olaf scholz einen schritt
auf uns zugeht und diesen flüchtlings
gipfel einberuft meine damen und herren
und letzter satz ich möchte lachen stamm
zitieren mit dem ich in den
koalitionsverhandlungen die basis
gemeinsam mit stefan thomé und auch
nancy faeser legen durfte für diese
fortschritts koalition in der
neuausrichtung der migrations und
flüchtlingspolitik die bei joachim
deswegen ist es unsere aufgabe so hast
du es gesagt in der sondersitzung des
nordrhein westfälischen
landtages dass wir diesen diktator mit
aufnahmebereitschaft und vor allem mit
mitmenschlichkeit entgegentreten und
dass wir alles dafür tun uns nicht
spalten zu lassen herzlichen dank für
eure aufmerksamkeit
soweit filiz polat hier für die grünen
hat ja auch noch mal die forderung
wiederholt dass es einen flüchtlings
gipfel geben soll auch das hat er ja der
deutsche städtetag gefordert klarer
bürger spricht jetzt für die l
linksfraktion sie ist sprecherin für
flucht politik
präsidenten liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der demokratischen fraktionen
seit beginn der russischen angriffe auf
die ukraine am 24 februar sind nach
angaben der vereinten nationen mehr als
drei millionen menschen aus der ukraine
geflohen die meisten von ihnen ins
nachbarland polen in deutschland wurden
bisher über
175.000 geflüchtete aus der ukraine
registriert mit zehntausenden mehr ist
zu rechnen die schutzsuchenden menschen
werden in der eu mit einer riesigen
hilfsbereitschaft und solidarität
aufgenommen sie bekommen unkompliziert
einen schutzstatus können hier arbeiten
und durften bei verwandten und bekannten
unterkommen soweit dies möglich war das
ist sehr gut dass die bundesregierung
aber auch die eu ebene hier schnell
gehandelt hat da dafür ein dankeschön
von unserer seite aber all das zeigt
auch wie eine solidarische
flüchtlingspolitik funktionieren kann
wenn der politische wille da ist
die aufnahme der
die vor krieg gewalt und zerstörung
fliehen wäre nicht möglich ohne das
beeindruckende engagement vieler
menschen die auf freiwilliger basis den
ankommenden unterstützen und für
unterkünfte und verpflegung sorgen
vielen dank an dieser stelle an alle
ehrenamtlichen die hier großartiges
geleistet haben und immer noch leisten
das gibt es ehrenamtliche engagement
kann nicht nur kann nicht auf dauer
staatliche strukturen ersetzen in vielen
städten und gemeinden fehlt es aktuell
an qualifiziertem personal an wohnungen
und weiteren ressourcen ich war letzte
woche selbst am berliner hauptbahnhof
und habe als freiwilliger im infodesk
unterstützt jeden tag kommen dort
tausende menschen an tendenz steigend
und die unterkünfte sind so voll dass
die menschen teilweise in zügen und
bussen übernachten müssen deshalb ist es
aus unserer sicht richtig dass jetzt
geflüchtete auch auf andere bundesländer
verteilt werden es geht aber nicht nur
um verpflegung und unterbringung sondern
auch um qualifizierte beratung schnelle
ihnen mal ein beispiel als ich letzte
woche am hauptbahnhof war berichtete mir
eine person dass sie ihren vater der aus
der ukraine geflogen war aus polen
abholen wolle der vater sei allerdings
dement und im gleichung seiner pflegerin
vor dem krieg geflüchtet die frage war
kann diese pflegerin die keine
ukrainische staatsbürgerschaft hat
ebenfalls nach deutschland kommen
bekommt sie hier auch schutz das ist nur
ein beispiel von vielen und es zeigt
dass es mehr professionelle
anlaufstellen für flüchteten braucht das
ist eine staatliche aufgabe hier muss
schnell gehandelt
die bundesregierung muss länder und
kommunen hier finanziell unterstützen
bei all der berechtigten freude über das
solidarische über die solidarische
aufnahme der geflüchteten aus der
ukraine dürfen wir nicht vergessen dass
die abschottung an der eu-außengrenze
gegenüber menschen unverändert weiter
geht polen ist immer noch dabei eine
fast sechs meter hohe mauer zur abwehr
von nichteuropäischen geflüchteten zu
bauen polnische sicherheitskräfte
schicken immer noch schutzsuchende
rechtswidrig in die kälte oder gar in
den tod zurück oder sperren sie in
geschlossene lager nach wie vor werden
schutzsuchende unter unwürdigen
bedingungen in hot spot lagern in den
griechischen inseln festgehalten und
nach wie vor ertrinken menschen im
mittelmeer oder werden an den eu
außengrenzen mit brutaler wald gewalt an
der einreise in die eu gehindert und
zurückgewiesen das ist nicht nur ganz
klar rechtswidrig weil das reglement
verbot eben eine absolute und notstands
feste garantie ist ist zeigt auch eine
doppelmoral im umgang mit geflüchteten
die aus meiner sicht ausdruck eines tief
sitzenden rassismus ist
dabei wollte doch klar sein dass man bei
menschen keinen unterschied macht wenn
sie vor kriegen viel es darf eben keine
geflüchteten erster und zweiter klasse
geben
und auch bei der aufnahme von
geflüchteten aus der ukraine kommt es zu
rassistischer diskriminierung auch wenn
sie als staatsministerin das verurteilen
was ich natürlich sehr begrüßen sieht
die realität leider anders aus
es kommt zu diskriminierung von menschen
die aus der ukraine fliehen zu
rassistischer diskriminierung
studierende aus afrikanischen ländern
werden an den grenzen auszügen geholt
durchsucht und schikaniert im
unterschied zur ukrainischen
staatsangehörigen haben sie zudem in der
regel keinen anspruch auf einen
unkomplizierten schutzstatus die frau
kollegin pollert hat es angekündigt
diese schutzlücken müssen aus meiner
sicht noch geschlossen werden
studierende aus drittstaaten müssen die
möglichkeit bekommen hier ihr studium
fortzusetzen wenn sie das möchten und
nun zum schluss noch ein wort zur union
frau lindholz ehrlich gesagt finde ich
es unerträglich dass sie in dieser
notsituation in der ausnahmsweise vieles
von der bundesregierung richtig gemacht
wird diesen wieder gefahren hierbei
reden und versuchen ängste zu schüren
ich habe ende gleich meine vorrede ja
dass wir hier solche schlimm vorgänger
für ihre politischen zwecke verwenden
ist einfach 30 wenn sie es wirklich
ernst meinen würden dann würden wir das
problem unter einer anderen überschrift
nämlich in welchen haftbarkeit lücken
diskutieren ein glück dass sie nicht
mehr in der video bringen
[Applaus]
dr stefan thomé spricht jetzt für die
fdp fraktion
stefan thomé sitz im anschluss für
inneres und hynix
präsidentin fertig kolleginnen und
kollegen die rede des ukrainischen
präsidenten wladimir lenski heute morgen
hier im deutschen bundestag hat mich
sicherlich uns alle extrem aufgewühlt
die von ihm beschworenen bilder von
stetten dem erdboden gleichgemacht
werden von krankenhäusern schulen
wohnhäusern die beschossen werden
tausende unschuldige ukraine die
gestorben sind all das ist nicht zu
ertragen und schon heute lässt sich
vorhersagen wo der platz wladimir putins
in der geschichte zu suchen sein wird in
der ahnengalerie der großen
menschheitsverbrechen damen und herren
zielinski hat von den mauern gesprochen
hinter denen wir uns nicht verschanzen
dürfen niemand weiß so genau wie wir
deutsche bauern sind unmenschlich ukr
darf nicht hinter einer mauer
verschwinden meine damen und herren
innerhalb der letzten drei wochen haben
bereits mehr als drei millionen menschen
vor allem frauen und kinder
die ukraine verlassen nur zum vergleich
in den flüchtlingslagern 2015 und 16
sind in diesen zwei jahren ungefähr 1,2
millionen asylanträge in deutschland
gestellt worden nach polen kam innerhalb
dreier wochen heute schon fast zwei
millionen menschen
das zeigt uns wir erleben die größte
fluchtbewegung die europa seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg erlebt hat und
vielleicht machen wir noch gar keine
vorstellung welche dimensionen diese
flucht noch annehmen
deshalb danken wir den vielen
ehrenamtlichen helfern die ihre freie
zeit oder ein freies zimmer den
ankommenden widmen oder für den
täglichen bedarf einkaufen all diese
menschen verdienen dank und respekt und
ich will weil ich dafür beispiele kenne
auch ausdrücklich erwähnen dass sich in
den freiwilligen helfern auch menschen
mit russischer herkunft wir finden die
voller scham für die kriegsverbrechen
sind die in diesen tagen in russischen
namen begangen werden und jetzt großen
an veränderungen in deutschland
ausgesetzt sind wir dürfen auch nicht
wir dürfen auch nicht putin gleichsetzen
mit russland oder putin gleichsetzen mit
allen menschen russisch sprechen oder
russischstämmige sind meine damen und
herren
aber natürlich stößt auf freiwilligkeit
irgendwo an ihre grenzen das gilt sowohl
im privaten wie auch im öffentlichen
bereich und deswegen dürfen es auch
nicht allein nur auf freiwilligkeit
verlassen wir sind voller anerkennung
für die vielen freiwilligen helfer und
ehrenamtler aber der rechtsstaat hat
auch eindeutige regeln wer welchen
beitrag leisten muss und folglich werden
wir diese regeln auch anwenden deswegen
hat die bundesregierung gestern die
verteilung auf der fina verteilung der
flüchtlinge nach dem königsteiner
schlüssel auf die bundesländer aktiviert
und das ist richtig so aber auch in der
eu müssen wir klare regeln definieren
die wir als rechts- und
wertegemeinschaft unseren humanitären
verpflichtungen gerecht werden wollen
und wer welchen beitrag erbringen
erbringen muss denn auch humanitär
pflichten sind pflichten mehr damen und
herren und deshalb begrüße ich dass die
bundesregierung darauf hinwirken wir
dass ein fairer europäische
verteilungsschlüssel angewandt wird so
dass ich nicht einige wenige hinter der
hilfsbereitschaft der vielen wegducken
können und wie die fehler die jahre 2015
16 nicht wiederholen
eine gerechte verteilung setzt natürlich
auch voraus dass sie wissen wer bei uns
ankommt und deswegen müssen wir die
menschen die hier ankommen auch erfassen
und registrieren denn nur wenn wir
wissen wie viele menschen ankommen wer
ankommt wer davon alte menschen sind
kinder familien oder alleinstehende nur
dann können wir die hilfen auch
zielgerichtet an den mann und an die
frau dann das kind bringen kinder die zu
weit kriegshandlungen miterleben mussten
sind traumatisiert müssen betreut werden
ältere menschen brauchen pflege und
betreuung und deshalb hat die
bundesregierung auch bereits begonnen
mit der registrierung der flüchtlinge
denn eine möglichst lückenlose
registrierung schützt auch die menschen
wie bei uns ankommen weil damen und
herren und damit all das europaweit
geschehen kann braucht es insgesamt eine
koordinierung durch die europäische
kommission und eine faire verteilung auf
die mitgliedstaaten der eu
meine damen und herren putins krieg gilt
in erster linie der ukraine aber in
zweiter linie soll auch dazu dienen
europa durch eine flüchtlingswelle zu
destabilisieren und indem wir diese
flüchtlingswelle gemeinsam europäisch
meistern durchkreuzen wir den plan des
russischen diktators und setzten gegen
die barbarei ein zeichen der
menschlichkeit wir zeigen dass unser
platz jetzt an die seite dekorieren und
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer ist
stephan thomae hat hier auch noch einmal
an die rede des iranischen präsidenten
wolodimir selensky erinnerte heute
morgen hier
zugeschaltet war und sich hier an das
parlament
gewendet hat falls sie die rede verpasst
haben finden sie diese natürlich auch
auf unserem königs youtube-kanal detlef
seif spricht jetzt für die
cdu/csu-fraktion
präsidentin meine damen und herren
lassen sie mich zunächst vorab deutlich
zum ausdruck bringen dass es völlig
unverständlich ist dass die
bundesinnenministerium heute diese
aktuellen stunde unentschuldigt
fernbleibt
die regierungsvertreter haben in den
letzten tagen im innenausschuss und bei
der gestrigen
regierungsbefragung
jegliche kritik an der bearbeitung der
vertriebenen krise von sich gewiesen
warum dann aber die hilferufe aus den
bundesländern
und wie kommt die deutsche
polizeigewerkschaft zu dem schluss dass
die bundesregierung noch nicht mal im
ansatz
einen plan hat wie so fordert der
deutsche städte und gemeindebund ein
koordiniertes vorgehen von bund ländern
und kommunen
die chefs der staatskanzleien sehen den
bund hier in der besonderen
verpflichtung die bundesweite
koordinierung schnell zu verbessern
umfangreiche lageberichte technische
unterstützung und vor allem ein
strukturiertes verteilungsverfahren sind
das gebot der stunde
wenn bundesverkehrsminister volker
wissing den ländern die schuld gibt und
sie auffordert frühzeitig in großem
umfang
aufnahmekapazitäten zu melden verkennt
er das hauptproblem wir haben es mit der
größten vertriebenen krise seit ende des
zweiten weltkriegs zu tun dass flucht
geschehen ist sehr dynamisch und niemand
kann die exakte zahl der vertriebenen
vorhersehen die vereinten nationen
rechnen mit bis zu acht millionen
menschen die die ukraine verlassen das
ist aber keine obergrenze
offensichtlich setzt putin seine
kriegsmaschinerie gegen die
zivilbevölkerung auch deshalb ein um
möglichst große flucht bewegung zu
verursachen und wir können auch in
deutschland keine zahlen prognostizieren
und genau hier auf das ist der
knackpunkt muss sich die bundesregierung
einstellen appel nummer eins an die
bundesregierung
verstecken sie sich nicht hinter den
ländern und kommunen es reicht nicht
wenn sie wie bisher auf die
flüchtlingsströme die in deutschland
ankommen reagieren gefragt sind jetzt
führung vorausschau und
planung und zwar eine planung die zu
erwartende flüchtlingszahl
berücksichtigt sonst werden wir vor
allem aber die flüchtlinge um die es
geht eine böse überraschung erleben
appell nummer zwei an die
bundesregierung es sollte
schnellstmöglich einen vertriebenen
gipfel statt finde es wirklich
erforderlich und entsprechen sie auch
dem vorschlag der deutschen
polizeigewerkschaft eine professionelle
aufbauorganisation muss auf den weg
gebracht werden appel nummer drei an die
bundesregierung tun sie alles um einen
missbrauch des vertriebenen schutzes zu
verhindern im innenausschuss haben sie
zwar erklärt dass sie den kreis der
schutz berechtigten wie er in dem
eu-beschluss aufgeführt ist nicht
erweitern wollen fakt ist aber dass
zunächst alle menschen die die aus der
ukraine kommen nach der rechtsverordnung
des bundesinnenministeriums vom siebten
märz 2022
keinen aufenthaltstitel benötigen keine
unterscheidung nach rechtmäßig
unrechtmäßig keine frage danach ob
stritt drittstaatsangehörige zurück in
ihre heimat können gefahrlos
es ist auch bundes freudigen dass
aktuell keine umfassende registrierung
der personen umgesetzt wird die
begründung der ministerin dass eine
rechtsgrundlage zur registrierung fehlt
ist nicht stichhaltig
ukrainische staatsangehörige können ganz
klar visumsfrei einreisen aber nichts
spricht dagegen dass sie im zuge eines
gesuchs registriert werden wie das
gesetz es vorsieht
und wenn die bundesinnenministerium
betont dass man doch bitte nicht die
menschen an der deutsch polnischen
grenze nochmals stundenlang in der kälte
warten lassen könne ist das richtig aber
bei einer professionellen umsetzung ist
das gar nicht erforderlich machen wir es
wie die polen die die registrierungen an
einen benefit knüpfen nämlich an
bestimmte staatliche leistungen und eine
gute und professionelle regierungsarbeit
fängt nicht erst an der deutschen grenze
an die enge zusammenarbeit mit den
behörden der ukrainischen
anrainerstaaten insbesondere mit polen
ist wichtig meine damen und herren das
schicksal der vom angriffskrieg
russlands betroffenen menschen berührt
uns alle öffnen wir unser hart möglichst
weit und unterstützen die ukraine und
ihre menschen aber bitte vergessen wir
den verstand nicht damit die hilfe
bestmöglich ankommt bei denen die es
benötigen und zwar nur bei denen die
wirklich schutzbedürftig sind vielen
dank
[Applaus]
größter luxus spricht jetzt für die
spd-fraktion
vielleicht ganz am anfang zu gehen herr
kollege sei wenn sie eben richtig
zugehört hätten hätten sie mitbekommen
dass die minister dass die ministerin
bei der mpk ist die jetzt gerade in den
minuten zu ende geht und das ist auch
der verschiebung der debatte geschuldet
ich würde sie bitten einfach da mal ein
bisschen auf dem teppich zu bleiben
darf nicht wir haben diese kollegen
begegnen wenige meter von diesem
rednerpult entfernt kommen tausende
menschen an die vor dem krieg in der
ukraine fliehen müssen als ich in der
vergangenen woche am bahnhof war stand
ich mitten unter ihnen nicht zu
übersehen war ihr in ihrem gesicht hand
der schrecken des krieges
traurige augen verängstigte blicke
kinder die unter schock einfach nur
verstummen mütter die irgendwie
funktionieren im fremden land
herausgerissen aus ihrem familienleben
sie wissen nicht ob sie ihre söhne ihre
brüder ihre männer ihre väter überhaupt
wieder sehen sie wissen nicht ob sie
ihre zurückgebliebenen ob sie ihre
zurückgeblieben angehörigen irgendwann
wieder in die arme schließen können
der krieg in der ukraine der krieg in
europa bringt schrecklichen leid für so
viele menschen er ist eine humanitäre
katastrophe für die es nur einen
schuldigen gibt präsident putin
seit beginn seines angriffskrieges sind
schon drei millionen menschen geflüchtet
und diese zahl steigt jede minute in dem
dieser krieg tobt sehr geehrte damen und
herren liebe kolleginnen kollegen die
eindringliche rede des ukrainischen
präsidenten seelands die heute morgen
hat und ich denke uns allen unsere große
verantwortung deutlich gemacht wir
müssen alles tun um diesen krieg zu
beenden
wir müssen alles tun um das leid der
menschen zu lindern ich bin dankbar dass
unsere regierung genau dies mit ihren
unermüdlichen friedensbemühungen sucht
und auch weiter versuchen muss lassen
sie uns dafür jenseits von
parteipolitischen inszenierungen
zusammenstehen und lassen sie uns
gemeinsam zeigen
deutschland steht solidarisch an der
seite der ukraine
sehr geehrte damen und herren wir
erleben die größte fluchtbewegung seit
dem zweiten weltkrieg
jede minute die wir hier zusammen sind
kommen weitere menschen schwangere
frauen menschen mit einer behinderung
ältere menschen neugeborene oder
unbegleitete minderjährige
was jetzt zählt ist eine schnelle und
unbürokratische hilfe ich bin froh dass
für diese hilfe gemeinsam im
schulterschluss auch mit unseren
europäischen partnern geben mit der
aktivierung der sogenannten eu
massenzustrom frisch linie bieten dir
unmittelbaren schutz wir gewähren einen
aufenthaltstitel und zugang zum
arbeitsmarkt sowie leistungs
berechtigung nach dem
asylbewerberleistungsgesetz
kinder können zur schule gehen und
erwachsene haben die möglichkeit an
integrationskursen teilzunehmen
angesichts des riesigen zustroms
unterstützt der bund mit mussten bei der
verteilung der menschen um überlastungen
an knotenpunkten zu verhindern
gleichzeitig helfen die mit arbeiten des
bundesamt für migration und flüchtlinge
als register behörde bei der erfassung
gemeinsam mit den ländern und kommunen
organisieren wir so die nötige hilfe
besonders wichtig ist mir liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen dass wir die
vielen kinder mit ihren schrecklichen
erlebnissen nicht alleine lassen wir
müssen kindern schnell eine
tagesstruktur geben wir müssen die
aufnahme in schulen in gemeinden in
vereinen in den alltag möglichst schnell
unterstützen wir müssen ihre seelischen
wunden heilen und hierfür kritische
soziale angebote bereitstellen
schutzlücken dürfen für die besonders
gefährdeten gruppen nicht entstehen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
gerade bei der unterbringung muster
kinderschutz oberste priorität haben die
bomben des krieges haben den so jungen
menschen nur wenigen sekunden ihre
kindheit genommen wir wollen alles dafür
tun ihnen diese kindheit hier
zurückzugeben sehr geehrte kolleginnen
und kollegen als ich vergangene woche am
bahnhof zwischen all den geflüchteten
menschen stand habe ich mich hilflos und
dankbar zugleich gefühlt hilflos
angesichts des leidens der menschen und
dankbar in einem land zu leben in dem es
so viel solidarität gibt denn neben all
den
denn neben all dem leid ist es eine
enorme hilfsbereitschaft solidarität
allgegenwärtig ich möchte mich ganz
herzlich bei allen bedanken die sich so
engagiert einsetzen
liebe kollegen kollegen jeder mensch der
auf der flucht ist braucht schutz sei es
aus der ukraine aus afghanistan aus
jemen oder aus einem anderen land jeder
der vor krieg und gewalt flüchtenden
mensch muss deshalb gleichermaßen
willkommen sein egal welcher
nationalität er angehört es ist unsere
politische und menschliche aufgabe alles
dafür zu tun um menschen auf der flucht
und in ihren heimatländern zu helfen ich
wünsche mir dass wir hier im parlament
von der großen hilfsbereitschaft der
menschen in unserem land leiten lassen
deutschland ist ein starkes land lassen
sie uns diese stärke nutzen lassen sie
uns parteiübergreifend alles dafür tun
den geflüchteten menschen
bestmöglichen schutz zu geben solange
dies nötig ist herzlichen dank
die unionsfraktion hat diese aktuelle
stunde hier verlangt und deswegen
diskutieren die abgeordneten über die
lage der ukrainischen flüchtlinge und es
ist in diesem krieg so dass besonders
diejenigen die den schutz besonders
brauchen eventuell gefährdet auch sind
schätzungsweise 90 prozent der mehr als
drei millionen menschen die aus der
ukraine gefroren sind sind frauen und
kinder
für die grünen spricht jetzt leeren
eckert
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen liebe
bürgerinnen und wir sehen die bilder der
menschen die gerade zu uns kommen die
frau kollegin hat es gerade
eindrucksvoll beschrieben erschöpft und
desorientiert sind verwandte und freunde
zurückgelassen mussten aus ihrem zuhause
enten das sind bald bilder in denen auch
mir die luft wegbleibt verzweiflung sich
auch auf uns auf mich überträgt
unsicherheit vor dem was kommt aber auch
wut auf den verursacht verursacher all
dieses leid ist
und in dieser emotion das wird
durchbrochen wenn ich sehe dass die
helferinnen ihre einsatzkleidung in
warnwesten die feuerwehrleute das thw
die anderen hilfsorganisationen kommen
und dann wächst meine entschlossenheit
dass wir alles tun diesen menschen zu
helfen und alles dazu tun der ukraine
bei seite zu stehen
jeden tag sind jetzt helfer im land
unterwegs im einsatz packen an da wird
nicht gefragt wer kommt da sondern wann
geht's los bei uns im ort wurde direkt
am nächsten tag schon überlegt welchen
ort wandeln wir um in eine unterkunft
welche touren allen haben wir wie bauen
wir die verpflegung auf und wie schnell
das geht habe ich bei meiner eigenen
feuerwehr erlebt da kam der
einsatzbefehl und plopp plopp plopp
sofort waren die zusagen da wer alles
kommt und wer mit aufbaut da finden
infoabend der stadt von freiwilligen für
freiwilligen denn die helfer kreise sind
ja immer noch aktiv da sagen jetzt die
die seit vielen jahren geflüchtete
betreuen die es geht in zolling zum
beispiel gibt es eine super anleitung
wie werden geflüchtete zu hause
aufgenommen im badisch so aus der
anwender sich dass man weiß die leute
wissen wovon sie reden wie mache ich die
meldung vordruck für die e mail alles da
unglaubliches engagement und ich weiß
dass es überall in unserer republik
menschen gibt die gerade mit aller kraft
dieses engagement auf die straße bringen
dieses engagement und unten das
ehrenamtliche aus den städten und
gemeinden das macht unser land stark und
sie stehen an der ersten stelle um
schutz zu bieten und die menschen
aufzunehmen
eine große aufgabe steht vor uns und
diesen elan dieser menschen die jetzt
gerade agieren den brauchen wir auch
hier wir müssen einfach
merken dazu gehört auch aus der
vergangenheit zu lernen
2015/2016 und das ist leider unter dem
feurigen bundesinnenminister nicht
passiert mit einer verkrampften debatte
verbunden auf was können wir jetzt stolz
sein und auch fast nicht was haben wir
geschafft und was nicht da haben wir
nicht aus den fehlern gelernt und uns
nicht verbessert
haben wir wirklich die hürden abgebaut
die uns mitgeteilt worden sind sind wir
auch die helferinnen und helfer
eingegangen ja vor ort selber ihre
abläufe optimiert haben feldbetten
knappheit gibt es schon wieder weil wir
nichts eingelagert haben ich bin der
meinung wir haben zu wenig getan um uns
zu verbessern drei kleine beispiele vor
dem hintergrund 2015 2016 gibt es das
sogenannte labor 5000 einer einheit
schnell aufbau war verlegbare an vielen
stellen jetzt im einsatz am flughafen
tegel um leute unterzubringen 5000 stück
einer einheit haben wir eine wird gerade
geschafft wir bräuchten vielmehr in der
aktuellen situation könnten wir so viel
besser damit helfen
zweites beispiel spontan helfer
hochwasser geflüchtete unterbringen
wieder hochwasser die art katastrophe
jedes mal das resümee es gibt spontan
helfer und wir haben nicht die struktur
und zu verknüpfen zu verbinden die
richtig einzusetzen abzulösen und es
kann ja nicht unser anspruch sein dass
wenn die staatliche struktur kommt dass
wir dann schlechter sind als das was
ehrenamtlich aufgebaut worden ist das
heißt jetzt in die spontan helfer
endlich gehen und lehren ziehen aus 2015
und die auch mitnehmen und umsetzen
und dann das thema anerkennung in jeder
rede wurde den helferinnen und helfern
gedankt und ich weiß dass viele sich
freuen darüber ich weiß aber dass viele
mehr als warme worte brauchen wir haben
in unserem koalitionsvertrag endlich die
helfer gleichstellung dass der
feuerwehrmann genau so behandelt wird
wie die helferin von dak wenn sie eine
nacht helfen und der eine zu hause
bleiben davon der anderen nicht so geht
es nicht wir brauchen die helfer
gleichstellung jetzt demnächst
ehrenzeichen für 2015 2016 gibt es immer
noch kein ehrenzeichen auch kleine
sachen wo wir sagen müssen das ist
anerkennung und wertschätzung und in den
letzten jahren gerade bei mir in meinem
wahlkreis weiß ich dass viele helfer
kreise auch gesagt haben wir wurden eher
als klotz am bein wahrgenommen als als
bereicherung das ändert sich jetzt
hoffentlich und das sollten wir dann
auch so in zukunft durchhalten
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
liebe bürgerinnen bürger lassen sie uns
das ehrenamt und unseren
bevölkerungsschutz jetzt gemeinsam
stärken und aus diesen krisen lehrern
und da geld investieren für die
unterbringung für die wertschätzung für
die helfer gleichstellung vielen dank
das für die grünen und die bund länder
konferenz von bundeskanzler olaf scholz
und den regierungschefs der 16
bundesländer ist mittlerweile zu ende
gegangen wir erwarten in kürze eine
pressekonferenz des bundeskanzlers wenn
die es werden wir uns dort natürlich in
live schalten wir hören jetzt auf eine
weitere stimme aus den ländern joachim
stamm stellvertretende ministerpräsident
von nordrhein-westfalen spricht text
damen und herren ich hab das gestern
hier ausgeführt wladimir putin will mit
der europa destabilisieren
unsere gesellschaften dich stabilisieren
er will uns auch spalten
und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen auch als
mitglied des bundesrates wo uns das gott
sei dank erspart bleibt im bundesrat
selbst jedenfalls eine solche partei
gibt es eben leider auch in diesem
parlament dann eine gruppierung die
genau diesem ziel von putin vorschub
leisten will aber die demokraten in
diesem haus sind stärker und wir werden
gemeinsam die solidarität mit den
menschen in der ukraine
verteidigen
neben solidarität mit den vertriebenen
wir sind in einer anderen situation ich
glaube dass das auch wichtig ist immer
wieder zu erklären es ist eine andere
situation als
2015 sie ist aber nicht weniger
herausfordernd
sie ist vielleicht sogar noch
herausfordernder
wir haben eine andere situation heitz
2015 ball momentan in großen mengen
frauen und kinder zu uns kommen und das
ist natürlich besonders herausfordernd
weil wir für die auch in den nächsten
wochen die entsprechenden angebote auch
in der betreuung und vor allem auch in
der bildung schaffen müssen
darauf sind wir ja so nicht vorbereitet
gewesen wir wissen alle um den mangel an
lehrerinnen und lehrern den wir in
deutschland haben wir wissen auch dass
wir nicht ausreichend
schulpsychologinnen und schulpsychologen
haben was die trauma betreuung angeht
das sind alles herausforderungen mit
denen wir zu tun haben haben auch nicht
genügend erzieherinnen und erzieher das
wird für uns alle eine ganz ganz
besondere herausforderung und
vollendet hat natürlich recht wenn sie
sagt dass es auch unsere aufgabe ist
gerade den frauen und kindern den
unbegleiteten minderjährigen einen
besonderen schutz zu geben
ich will das aber ganz deutlich sagen
das wird auch deswegen eine besondere
herausforderung weil so viele in so
kurzer zeit jetzt kommen und auch das
ist ein unterschied zu
2015 und ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das
wirklich alle in dieser debatte
verstanden haben und ich rede nicht nur
von der debatte hier in diesem haus
sondern ich rede auch darüber wie das
thema in europa bisher diskutiert worden
ist wo sich hauptstädte zu wort melden
die sagen ja es ist dann auch bereit
zwei oder dreitausend menschen
aufzunehmen das wird nicht reichen
brauchen eine andere solidarität es sind
allein in polen in drei wochen knapp
zwei millionen menschen angekommen wo
leistet großartiges ich hab heute mit
einer polnischen delegation sprechen
können aber polen wird nicht mehr viele
menschen aufnehmen können
wenn gute ideen vertreibungs terror so
weiter fortsetzt dann werden in den
nächsten drei wochen wieder zwei bis
drei millionen menschen in die
europäische union kommen
und viele werden alleine von der
geografischen lage dann natürlich
deutschland ansteuern es gibt ja den
wunsch möglichst nah an der heimat zu
bleiben weil auch das ist ein
unterschied zumindest zu teilen
derjenigen von die
2015/2016 gekommen sind dass es einen
unmittelbaren wunsch gibt so schnell wie
möglich wieder zurückzukehren
aber es wird jetzt eben um die
notsituation gehen wie bekommen wir
diese menschen jetzt untergebracht
und wenn wir denen gerecht werden wollen
mit den standards wie das eben hier
angemahnt worden ist dann wird es nur
gehen wenn wir die internationale
verteilung hinbekommen wir werden es so
das muss man dann auch sagen wir sagen
immer gerne wir schaffen das und wir
wollen das schaffen und ich bin auch
überzeugt wir werden das schaffen aber
wir werden es eben nur schaffen wenn es
auch diese internationale und
europäische solidarität gibt wenn
beispielsweise die vereinigten staaten
wenn kanada wenn auch australien aber
auch die anderen europäischen länder
wirklich große kontingente auch
übernehmen sonst können wir den schutz
auf dem niveau wir hier beispielsweise
von der kollegin lindholz vorhin
gefordert worden ist gar nicht leisten
aber ich will das auch dazu sagen
ich gehe davon aus dass es gelingen wird
diese internationale solidarität auch zu
organisieren aber dennoch werden alleine
auch die zahlen die menschen die wir
hier in deutschland bei uns aufnehmen
eine historische herausforderung
und es gibt auch einen unterschied zur
polnischen gesellschaft was die aufnahme
angeht wir loben dass jetzt alle das was
so fantastisch funktioniert hat in polen
ansagen zu lesen wir verlassen den
bundestag an dieser stelle um in die
pressekonferenz von bundeskanzler olaf
scholz zu gehen
zwei millionen menschen
und da hat jetzt fast jeder daneben auch
privat jemanden aufgenommen die
polnische delegation hat mir eben noch
mal eindrucksvoll geschildert dass sie
ohne flüchtlingslager bisher aus
gekommen sind das werden wir hier nicht
schaffen ich habe mir nordrhein
westfalen bei mir 30.000 in der
ukrainischen community und die sind
natürlich jetzt auch dabei menschen
aufzunehmen aber es ist natürlich eine
ganz andere dimension als das in polen
der fall gewesen ist und deswegen
mobilisieren wir gerade alle verfügbaren
flächen alle hallen
aber das sage ich auch dazu bund länder
und kommunen wir brauchen eine noch
bessere koordination und ich habe
gestern hier an dieser stelle ja ganz
bewusst auch ein nationalen flüchtlings
gipfel darum gebeten auch im namen der
kommunen und wenn die kollegin polat
jetzt darauf hinweist dass der
bundeskanzler dazu einladen will dann
bin ich da ausgesprochen dankbar dass
jetzt so zügig gehandelt würde ich
begrüße das ausdrücklich und ich sag
auch für uns in nordrhein westfalen wir
werden dann sehr kurz danach dann auch
von unserer seite aus einen
entsprechenden gipfel machen um dann mit
den hilfsorganisationen und allen
beteiligten das auch entsprechend zu
koordinieren ich glaube das ist das was
jetzt notwendig ist um eine herzliche
bitte
meine herzliche bitte an sie alle wir
wissen es gibt in bälde landtagswahlen
im saarland auch bei uns in
nordrhein-westfalen in schleswig
holstein
und wir sind alle menschen und es ist
natürlich verführerisch auch bei diesem
thema parteipolitische geländegewinne zu
machen
ich kann sie alle als fraktionen als
vertreter eines landes nur herzlich
darum bitten zu
versuchen dies zu verhindern wir sind es
auch den ehrenamtlerinnen und
ehrenamtlern die sich momentan vor ort
verausgaben sind wir es schuldig dass
wir hier gemeinsam handeln wir werden
mit dem
wir werden viel improvisieren müssen
es ist aber eben auch notwendig dass es
top down systematisch entscheidungen
gibt wenn dafür jetzt der weg geebnet
wird bin ich dafür sehr dankbar ich will
an dieser stelle aber auch den
bürgerinnen und bürgern ganz offen sagen
und auch den ukrainerinnen trainern die
zu uns kommen wir müssen uns auch so
ehrlich machen und sagen es wird nicht
alles so klappen wie wir uns das
wünschen es wird immer wieder
hilfsangebote auch auf zuruf geben
müssen es wird improvisiert werden
müssen aber je mehr wir hier gemeinsam
zusammen stehen und nicht den
individuellen fehler bei irgendeinem
organisations ablauf suchen sondern
gemeinsam unterstützen wie kann man
vielleicht diesen fehler schnell
ausbügeln dann werden wir das auch
tatsächlich gemeinsam schaffen haben sie
hat sich dann für die aufmerksam
der stellvertretende ministerpräsident
von nordrhein-westfalen joachim stammte
war das mitglied der fdp und auf ihn
folgt nun dorothee bär stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der
unionsfraktion hier in dieser aktuellen
stunde zur lage der ukraine schön wie
flüchtlinge
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren ich da vielleicht noch mal kurz
darauf hinweisen warum wir auch als cdu
csu bundestagsfraktion
diese aktuelle stunde beantragt haben
weil uns geht's eben jetzt um die lage
der ukrainischen flüchtlinge um ihre
versorgung um ihre registrierung das
haben die kolleginnen und kollegen
lindholz und auch schon deutlich gemacht
aber es geht um die organisation der
verteilung um die sicherstellung der
teilhabe aber ganz besonders eben auch
um den schutz der kinder um den schutz
der frauen um den schutz der mutter ist
betont deswegen weil ich jetzt außer vom
kollegen stammt da relativ wenig dazu
gehört habt auch zur hilfe der
bundesregierung was wir jetzt konkret
auch leisten was wir jetzt konkret auch
machen um das chaos an den bahnhöfen zu
beseitigen um die registrierung in den
griff zu bekommen und deswegen ist
natürlich die kritik schon gegeben dass
nicht nur die bundesinnenministerium
nicht da ist bundesfamilienministerin
ist gesundheitlich entschuldigt in
ordnung aber dass kein einziger minister
keine einzige ministerin der
bundesregierung jetzt heute hier ist
finde ich ehrlicherweise dem thema nicht
angemessen das muss man auch mal so
deutlich sagen
und wir brauchen die hilfe eben jetzt in
unterschiedlichen stufen wir brauchen
sie jetzt kurzfristig aber wir brauchen
sie mittel- und langfristig und deswegen
möchte ich jetzt auch schon mal betonen
dass es nicht in der vahr wochen meist
stimme vor herausforderungen mussten wir
wieder alles nicht wie es neulich in der
racket zu hören war nein wir wissen ja
jetzt schon dass es nicht nur jetzt um
die aktuellen stunden und tage geht
sondern wir werden natürlich auch in den
nächsten wochen monaten und auch jahren
hilfe leisten müssen nicht nur vor ort
sondern eben auch hilfe im eigenen land
und was mich wirklich schon betroffen
macht es die situation die wir heute
früh hier im plenum hatten wir haben
eine bundesregierung die auch ins amt
gekommen ist und ein bundeskanzler weil
er flächendeckend in ganz deutschland
respekt plakatiert respekt wo war der
respekt heute früh da muss ich mal ganz
offen sagen das geht einfach nicht was
ihr abgezogen wurde lässt mangelnden
respekt
das ist auch mangelnde empathie und
befolgt zu den technischen punkten kann
muss ich schon sagen gerade die frauen
und kinder die schwer traumatisiert sind
sie dann auch jetzt hier in deutschland
einem weiteren trauma auszusetzen wenn
sie sich nicht sicher fühlen wir haben
alle diese artikel gelesen und ich meine
jetzt nicht nur artikel in zeitungen mit
wenigen buchstaben oder in großen
buchstaben sondern auch wenn man sich
mal die langen artikel in der zeit zum
beispiel durch liest was hier frauen und
kinder durch machen können dann würde
ich mir einfach wünschen dass diese
bundesregierung auch mehr empathie an
den tag legt und sich wirklich 24/7
reinhängt die kolleginnen der spd am
freundschaft wird schon alles nein das
tun sie nicht wir hatten gestern im
familienausschuss eignet ist ich habe
die staatssekretärin dann auch gefragt
nach ihrer beteiligung des
familienministeriums
dieses jahr wir haben ein krisenstab
einmal die woche ein mal die woche ja
das ist nämlich federführend zuständig
so was kann ich nicht mehr alles kann
kein bürger da draußen hören wie er ist
nicht federführend zuständig die gesamte
bundesregierung ist federführend
zuständig und erwartet das bmf auch
zeitlich dabei ist da erwarte ich dass
sie auch das landesverkehrsministerium
ist doch auf jeden tag in einem
krisenstab im kanzleramt und es muss das
familienministerium auch und heute ist
nicht der richtige zeitpunkt um über
verstellungen der ministerin an der art
zu sprechen okay aber wenn ich schon
einmal nicht verantwortung für menschen
übernommen habe habe ich die
verantwortung zu übernehmen und damals
wurde die frage gestellt
damals wurde die frage gestellt auch an
ihre mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter wo
es eigentlich platz für mich wo es platz
für meine rolle ich kann ihnen sagen
frau spielen jetzt welche platz viele
rollen sich um kinder zu kümmern sich
abzusprechen mit den länderministerien
und ländern minister nämlich in der
bildungspolitik in der bildungspolitik
wo sind denn die plätze auch da in den
kindergarten in den kindertagesstätten
in den schulen ja wollte mit so vielen
landräten und bürgermeistern ihnen
telefoniert alles was sie jetzt machen
machen sie eigenverantwortlich und es
kann und melodisch sein programm nicht
zufällig in deutschland an wo habe ich
jetzt glück dass ein kommunalpolitiker
alles auf die reihe bekommen das muss
natürlich vom bund koordiniert werden
und diese ständige wieso schon auch in
rheinland pfalz ist play game und länder
das wollen wir alles nicht das finde ich
das ehrlich einfach schade und es spielt
mit den traumata der kinder deswegen
fordern wir ein verband dieser stelle
jetzt ein
wir wissen dass wir einen großen pakt
brauchen wir haben jetzt die chance vor
die welle zu kommen die familien werden
nicht in wenigen wochen wieder in die
ukraine zurück können das heißt wir
müssen für sichere schulen versichere
kita sorgen wir brauchen zugang zu allen
leistungen der kinder und jugendhilfe
und es reicht auch nicht wie die
berliner bürgermeisterin gesagt hat wir
müssen einfach nur einen stuhl mehr
hinstellen das reicht nicht wir brauchen
schulpsychologen wir brauchen
kinderärzte wir brauchen schon
sozialarbeiter wir brauchen dolmetscher
wir brauchen sprachlehrer wir können
auch der kollege stammkraft wir haben
nicht genug erzieherinnen da fand ich
auch das riecht geflüchteten
erzieherinnen und erzieher jetzt schon
mit frauen kolleginnen am vortag eine
minute mehr gekommen ich bin sofort
wir benötigen kind gesehen
informationsmöglichkeiten wir brauchen
sportangebote wir brauchen in angebot
und im leben einfach eine
bundesregierung die nicht dienst nach
vorschrift mag 124 70 den hintern
aufreißen
[Applaus]
ferien mit deutlicher kritik an der
arbeit der bundesregierung
auch der europarat hat schon vor der
gefahr des menschenhandels mit
ukrainischen flüchtlingen gewarnt vor
betrügerischen angeboten von transport
unterbringung und arbeit hegel
entspricht jetzt für die spd-fraktion
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen
kollegen als erstes zum unsäglichen
vortrag von mercurio wer wie die fdp die
mit dem massenmörder und antisemiten als
hat ist der sollte zum thema flach
flucht einfach nur eines tun die klappe
halten
komme ich kann mich aber jetzt nachdem
wir das erstmal abgearbeitet haben komme
ich jetzt zur aus meiner sicht leicht
konzertierten empörung aktion der union
und da muss man tatsächlich auch noch
mal über heute morgen sprechen aber das
wurde zum teil eben fortgesetzt man kann
sich gerne aufregend man kann auch
ansetzungen von debatten einfordern
unterschiedlicher meinung sein das ist
gar nicht die frage ist es nicht dass
das ist es eine frage des viehs und der
tonalität und wenn sie was sie heute
morgen gemacht haben und jetzt ist
wieder gemacht haben den eindruck
erwecken wollen dass die koalition
weniger als sie an der seite der ukraine
an der seite der opfer und der
geflüchteten stunde ist das schlicht
unanständig sie
sie tragen auf dem rücken der opfer
unter geflüchteten parteipolitisch viele
aus und das ist unredlich und das ist
noch unredlicher wenn sie gar keine
alternativen konzepte vorlegen ich
erinnere mal war ja herr merz auf dem
weg ist besonders staatstragend zu sein
und ein staatsmann sein zu wollen an
helmut schmidt der hat sich sonstwie
gestritten mit franz josef strauß und
helmut kohl aber in der krise hat der
erhaltung und hat man miteinander
vernünftig und anständig gesprochen
davon sind sie weit war entfernt
und da sie ja offensichtlich an sowas
wie retrograden post co valmont mentaler
amnesie sprich total vergesslichkeit in
bezug auf ihre eigene regierung auch in
den ländern und auf bundesebene leiden
leiste ich etwas
unterstützungs hilfe ich war selbst teil
des verhandlungsteams zu migrations
paket im rahmen dessen hat uns minister
seehofer noch angehalten bloß nicht den
forderungen der union nach zu geben das
muss man sich vorstellen den
restriktiven flüchtlings feindlichen
forderungen er selbst auch im ausschuss
im übrigen zum zweiten haben wir ja
stunden verbracht um sie hinzuweisen auf
die situation von bruno rabl haben sie
gewarnt vor dem antrag zentrum konzept
alle die punkte waren ihn nicht wichtig
plötzlich entdecken sie ihre sorge um
zuneigung und geborgenheit sowohl
nachermittlungen das finde ich
unglaubwürdig und das ist unredlich und
es ist auch aus der zeit gefallen wir
selber wissen auch um defizit und fehler
die korrigieren wir in dieser koalition
auch integrationspolitisch und wir
ändern wir haben nicht vergessen was wir
gemacht haben wir haben eine
fehlerkultur sie haben eine kultur des
vergessens die nur parteipolitisch und
parteitaktisch motiviert ist das an sich
ist jetzt und rheine grünes träges macht
mich wütend für mich unerträglich
und ich brauche etwas hin wo sie sich
jetzt so sorgen um die kommunen wehren
steht denn am altschulden vor für
kommunen seit jahren im wege wer hat
sich nicht bemüht die
finanzierungssituation der kommunen auch
der verschuldeten kommunen deutlich zu
verbessern das war glaube ich nicht grün
das war nicht die sp das war auch nicht
entscheiden die fdp aber die union in
der letzten koalition
kommunen die nicht hinreichend
ausgestattet sind sind
selbstverständlich in der jetzigen
situation unterstützung bedürftig aber
wenn man strukturell seit jahren nicht
blockiert sondern unterstützt hätte
wären wir nicht in der situation also
ein bisschen mehr ehrlichkeit
anstatt sich nämlich abzuarbeiten ans
fräser und frau spiegel anstatt so eine
recht billige nein sehr billige
personalisierung zu betreiben sollten
sie sich lieber orientieren an den
menschen die gekommen sind sie in den
mittelpunkt zu stellen die geflüchteten
die eben nicht lernen die ich war selber
in meinem bus mit ungefähr 50 personen
die unheimlich still sind die dankbar
sind die nachdenklich sind die nur ein
interesse haben nämlich zu gucken dass
ihre liebsten angehörigen in der ukraine
überleben und die jetzt schon nachdenken
wie sie hier arbeit finden wie ihr
abschluss anerkannt werden sie sollten
wir in den mittelpunkt unseres
interesses stellen und einmal vergessen
was mir für ambitionen bei künftigen
wahlen haben ich würde dringend darum
bitten sich das einmal in den kopf zu
setzen
und soweit nicht hinreichend informiert
bin ist es nun nicht so dass auch die
cdu-ministerpräsidenten
fundamental opposition gegen die pläne
der bundesregierung üben nein man sucht
am ende gemeinsam einen weg so wie ihn
auch herbe stammt beschrieben hat
nüchtern sachlich pragmatisch
problemorientiert und nicht populistisch
und auf dem eigenen gelände gewinn
ausgerichtet und genau deswegen gelegen
kümmern wir uns um fragen der
registrierung und zerteilung
finanzierung und unterstützung die
redezeit war zu ende und letzter hinweis
es gab mal einen wirtschaftsminister der
war sozialdemokratische fraktion die spd
die regel eine gemeinschaftsaufgabe
integration demokratie einsetzte für
soziales wohnen und herr kollege andere
fragen in der letzten flüchtlingskrise
nicht die gewalt erleben die spd und wir
setzen unsere politik und vielen dank
selbst rednerin in dieser aktuellen
stunde ist für die spd-fraktion die
kollegin der türk nachbau und der tritt
nach fahrersitz im ausschuss für
menschenrechte und humanitäre hilfe
zwischendurch auch mal luft holen
gut dass wir heute dieses thema hier
besprechen
es ist die grösste vertriebenen krise
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg die lage ist
ernst dass es uns glaube ich ein bewusst
viele menschen aus der ukraine vor allem
frauen mittag kinder und kranke und
ältere menschen mussten alles
zurücklassen und ins benachbarte ausland
ziehen diese frauen und kinder die
schutz bei uns suchen haben ihr leben
ihren glauben an frieden und freiheit in
kleine koffer und tüten gepackt der
staub des krise des krieges und der
verwüstung projekt noch ihr haar
ukrainerinnen berichtet mir vorgestern
dass sie fassungslos vor den mauerresten
ihrer häuser standen keine türen keine
fenster keine dächer mehr die ihre
familien schützen könnten sie berichten
dass ihre kinder verstummt sind in
diesen trümmern diesen kinder ihre
kindheit zurück zwischen diesen trümmern
lassen frauen ihre männer und söhne
zurück viele wurden durch die
warnsirenen und bomben mitten aus ihrem
leben gerissen standes vor kurzem noch
im beruf mussten über nacht ihre
habseligkeiten packen und sind nun auf
dem weg in eine ungewisse zukunft drei
millionen geflüchtete haben die ukraine
bereits verlassen unsere nachbarn polen
rumänien tschechien slowakei und moldau
leisten einen unermesslichen
logistischen und humanitären beitrag
indem sie die erste aufnahme dieser
menschen gewährleisten es erfüllt uns
mit dank dass die bürger innen in polen
1,6 millionen menschen überwiegend über
private unterkünfte herr schwarz gesagt
aufgenommen haben als bundesrepublik
deutschland helfen die ebenfalls
solidarisch und vor allem nach kräften
wir tun was wir können ich bin sehr froh
dass unser
gesundheitsministerium die verlegung von
verletzungen versorgungs bedürftigen
menschen nach deutschland zugesichert
hat und dass deutschland hier bei der
medizinischen versorgung dabei eine sehr
zentrale rolle übernimmt neben den zügen
aus ton mit tausenden die täglich in
berlin ankommen übernimmt deutschland
kurzfristig kurzfristig 2005 märkte
flüchtete aus moldau mit polen befinden
uns im ständigen austausch um auch
weitere menschen noch aufzunehmen indem
wir die schutzsuchenden
verantwortungsbewusst gerecht und
solidarisch in ganz europa parteien
nehmen die den druck von haupt
betroffenen ländern in osteuropa wird
zeigen aber auch dass wir handlungsfähig
sind dass wir ressourcenorientiert eine
europäische lösung herbeiführen wir
haben eine ist zwar nicht viel und nicht
alles aber wir haben einen ist aus der
flüchtlingskrise von 2015 gelernt wir
werden diesmal nicht
auseinanderdividieren lassen die
zersetzung strategie von putin und seine
helferinnen und helfern hier in
deutschland wird ins leere laufen wir
werden alles daran setzen dass qualität
die wahrung des völkerrechts und der
europäische gedanke sich am ende
durchsetzen und ich hoffe dass wir auch
gelernt haben dass der schmerz der opfer
eines unmenschlichen krieges keiner
kommt farbe hat es gibt keine guten und
keine schlechte schutz suchenden lassen
sie uns diese unmenschlichkeit mit
unserer menschlichkeit begegnen und zwar
allen menschen gegenüber
das mindeste was wir den aufkommenden
als aufnahme und land bieten müssen sind
schutz und sicherheit vor allem den
frauen und kindern
darauf sollen sich die schutzsuchenden
bei uns verlassen können wir werden
ausreichend zuverlässig und sichere
unterkünfte bieten damit niemand sich
gezwungen sieht in der hoffnung auf
einen warmen schlafplatz in ein fremdes
auto zu steigen und dann nicht mehr
zurückzukommen es wird eine verbesserte
aufklärung auf russisch und in
ukrainischer sprache geben damit
traumatisierte frauen und kinder nicht
opfer von kriminellen in deutschland
werden die aufklärung wird auch die
freiwilligen helferinnen und helfer und
die behörden umfassen es ist gut dass
das innenministerium und die
polizeibehörden diese gefahr erkennen
und die bundespolizei hier auch schon
aktiv geworden ist es ist unbedingt
verhindert werden dass wieder tausende
geflüchtete kinder verschwinden ich
erinnere daran dass im zuge der
flüchtlingskrise 25 10 216 tausende
unbegleitete kinder aus syrien und
afghanistan auf der flucht verschwunden
sind kein mensch weiß wo sie sind leider
hat den innenminister damals auch nicht
wirklich interessiert der ukrainische
präsident selbst sprach heute morgen von
mauern die durch europa gehen und dass
wir uns hinter diesen mauern verstecken
ich empfinde es inzwischen ein bisschen
anders zum ersten mal nach sehr langer
zeit erleben wir dass europa die mauer
niedergerissen hat und geschlossenen
hilfsbereitschaft und geeint in der
verurteilung von putins kriegsverbrechen
steht das war übrigens auch im europarat
zu spüren wo wir vorgestern eine
historische aber auch sehr traurige
entscheidung
mussten gleich fertig 46 mitgliedstaaten
haben in ein staat russland aus der
europarat ausgeschlossen alle
demokratischen parteien im bundestag
wenn ich sehr dankbar dass sie mit
dieser entscheide zum auslegen und wenn
sie so beschritten
jetzt geht es unseren beitrag zu leisten
damit diese euro einsetze und
ihre wertvolle arbeit
weiterführen
das war die aktuelle stunde zur lage der
ukrainischen geflüchteten und natürlich
brauchen die geflüchteten informationen
die bundesregierung hat ein
informationsportal im im netz gerade
frei geschaltet heute germany for you
crane punkt.de und vor wird da als vier
geschrieben dort sind informationen und
leistungen auf ukrainisch russisch
deutsch und englisch verfügbar zum
beispiel zur unterbringung und zur
versorgung
wir kommen nun zum nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt zum
heizkostenzuschuss wird es dort hier
diskutiert werden die ampel koalition
hat den heizkostenzuschuss für menschen
mit wenig einkommen noch einmal
verdoppelt das bedeutet dass zum
beispiel ein personen haushalte nicht
wie ursprünglich geplant 135 euro
bekommen sondern 270 euro hintergrund
sind die gestiegenen öl- und gaspreise
die natürlich auch das heizen noch
einmal viel teurer machen und da soll es
nun eben mehr geld geben das geld soll
ohne antrag direkt auf das konto
derjenigen überwiesen werden die dafür
berechtigt sind es gibt dazu auch
entschließungsanträge von union und
links fraktion jeweils denen das nicht
weit genug geht so wie auch ein antrag
der linksfraktion für die
bundesregierung für die bundesregierung
spricht jetzt chance käsetheke
parlamentarische staatssekretärin für
wohnen stadtentwicklung und bauwesen
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wie sieht gute politik aus gute
politik packt ein akutes problem an sie
hilft denjenigen die wirklich hilfe
brauchen und sie handelt schnell und
unbürokratisch mit dem
heizkostenzuschuss
macht die ampel koalition genau das
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen bevor der
schreckliche krieg in der ukraine begann
sind die energiepreise stark gestiegen
durch die verwerfungen des krieges ist
das noch mal schlimmer geworden
betroffen sind vor allem bürgerinnen und
bürger die eh schon weniger haben denen
wollen wir helfen und das machen wir
jetzt
man kann seine heizung nicht von heute
auf morgen wechseln den preisanstiegen
sind die bürgerinnen und bürger also
einfach ausgeliefert doch wohnen ist ein
grundrecht und muss bezahlbar sein das
ist die oberste prämisse unseres
ministeriums und unserer regierung
deswegen haben wir den
heizkostenzuschuss als erste initiative
aus dem bundesministerium auf den weg
gebracht
wir unterstützen mit dem
heizkostenzuschuss
gezielt bürgerinnen und bürger mit
geringem einkommen rentnerinnen und
rentner alleinerziehende und menschen in
ausbildung bekommen den zuschuss direkt
überwiesen ohne antrag diese menschen
brauchen unterstützung und die geben wir
ihnen jetzt
wir wollen keine dies kann politik an
der zapfsäule machen die führt im
schlimmsten fall zu höheren profiten bei
ölkonzernen nein wir machen verteilungs
gerechte politik mit der ampel
rollbahnen bezahlbar sein liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
mein dank geht heute auch ausdrücklich
an die abgeordneten die in den letzten
tagen unter hochdruck an dem gesetz
gearbeitet haben als wir den
heizkostenzuschuss auf den weg gebracht
haben herstellen der ukraine noch kein
krieg durch die preis explosion hat
haben die zuständigen ausschüsse im
deutschen bundestag zu recht die höhe
des zuschusses neu diskutiert und es ist
genau richtig dass wir jetzt schnell
handeln und reagiert haben und den
heizkostenzuschuss verdoppeln
eine familie mit zwei kindern wird so
490 euro zusätzlich bekommen insgesamt
helfen wir 2,1 millionen menschen das
ist soziale politik die bei den
bürgerinnen und bürgern direkt ankommt
die union hat sich sowohl im
bauausschuss als auch im
haushaltsausschuss gegen diese
unterstützung art ausgesprochen und dem
gesetzesentwurf nicht zugestimmt liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der union ich
habe mir auch ihren entschließungsantrag
noch mal angeschaut sich fordern und ich
zitiere den heizkostenzuschuss auf ein
auskömmliches maß zu erhöhen wie
unkonkret soll es werden frage ich mich
da wollen sie behaupten dass 270 euro
für single-haushalte und 490 euro für
familien mit zwei kindern nicht
auskömmlich sind
regierungspolitik bedeutet für uns sich
festzulegen anzupacken und versprochenes
umzusetzen wir stellen keine leben
forderungen
der heizkostenzuschuss ist eine
dringliche entlastung die bei denen
ankommt die sie wirklich brauchen und
weitere werden wir in der ampel
koalition auf den weg bringen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen lassen sie uns
hier und jetzt ein wichtiges zeichen für
soziale gerechtigkeit stellen vielen
dank
über den gesetzentwurf der
koalitionsfraktionen werden die
abgeordneten auch nach dieser debatte
abstimmen
in nächste rednerin ist anne könig nun
für die cdu csu sitzt sie im ausschuss
für wohnen stadtentwicklung bauwesen und
kommunen und das hier ist ihre erste
rede im deutschen bundestag
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin verehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen der furchtbare
angriffskrieg des mutigen regimes
verursacht in diesen wochen
unermessliches leid in der ukraine
wir unterstützen die bundesregierung in
ihrer haltung gegen diesen krieg und
helfen den menschen die als flüchtlinge
zu uns kommen zugleich wollen wir uns
aber auch um die folgen für die menschen
in unserem land kümmern wir sehen dass
dieser krieg die ohnehin schon massiv
gestiegenen energiepreise weiter in die
höhe treibt ein bereits bisher großes
kostenproblem beim heizen tanken und
bauen wird dadurch noch größer
unter diesen kostendruck leiden menschen
die sozialleistungen erhalten besonders
gebeutelt sind aber auch oftmals die die
bislang ohne transferleistungen
ausgekommen sind die energiekosten krise
hat längst die mitte unserer
gesellschaft erreicht
in diesem zusammenhang hat mich in den
letzten wochen einen brief besonders
bewegt dem ihr ein schulkind aus meinem
wahlkreis geschrieben hat die 11 jährige
meike berichtet von der situation ihrer
familie die eltern betreiben ein kleines
ladengeschäft und die explodierenden
energiekosten gefährden inzwischen ihre
wirtschaftliche existenz maike schrieb
mir auch für familien die bisher genug
verdient haben und darum kein wohngeld
erhalten wird es jetzt schwierig alles
zu bezahlen und wissen sie ich meine die
bundesregierung muss auch diesen
menschen eine antwort auf die preis
explosion geben
wir sollten dabei auch nicht vergessen
dass die bundesministerin ja schließlich
auch stadtentwicklung zuständig ist und
das einzelhandelsangebot in unseren
innenstädten ist doch nun auch schon
konkret durch die
energiepreisentwicklung gefährdet mit
dem von der bundesregierung vorgelegten
heizkostenzuschuss einem einmaligen
kratzen sie jetzt leider nur an der
oberfläche der energiepreis krise sie
werden damit nicht einmal den von ihnen
selbst formulierten anspruch gerecht
denn laut ihren eigenen aussagen sollen
die von der gestiegenen preisentwicklung
betroffenen haushalte kurzfristig und
spürbar entlastet werden für eine
kurzfristige hilfe kommt ihr zuschuss zu
spät und vom spürbar kann bei ihrer
einmal hilfe selbst nach den hastigen
nachbesserungen leider auch keine rede
sein
ganz offensichtlich wurden ihre
ursprünglichen vorschläge doch ziemlich
schnell von der realität weiterer
preissteigerungen überrollt die
betroffenen konnten ihre an ihren
anfänglichen zuschuss von 135 euro doch
nur so verstehen dass sie die größe
ihres problems einfach nicht ernst
nehmen mit ihren über nacht zusammen
geschriebenen änderungsanträgen
reagieren sie nun immerhin auch die
kritik der unionsfraktion
aber irgendwie gelingt nicht mehr aber
ihnen gelingt nicht mehr als eine
gewisse politische schadensbegrenzung
sie haben nämlich nach wie vor nicht
erkannt dass man ein länger andauerndes
sich immer weiter verschärfenden und
wohl strukturelles problem eben nicht
mit einer einmaligen hilfszahlung lösen
kann und sie springen auch insofern zu
kurz weil sie sich nicht trauen ihre
änderungen in die einzelnen fach gesetze
einzubauen sie stellen stattdessen ein
neues gesetz stumpf leben die bisherige
rechtsordnung wenn jetzt 16 bundesländer
erst tätig werden damit das gesetz seine
wirkung entfaltet geht für die menschen
die hilfe brauchen wertvolle zeit
verloren
vor allem aber ist der empfängerkreis
ihrer hilfe viel zu eng wenn die
energiekosten krise längst in der mitte
unserer gesellschaft angekommen ist dann
reicht es eben nicht aus nur einen
kleinen empfängerkreis zu helfen was sie
hier machen ist bestenfalls eine erste
hilfe aktion für wenige das ist leider
weit entfernt von einer echten
energiekosten senken strategie für viele
ihr heizkostenzuschuss mag gut gemeint
sein aber er ist trotz aller
nachbesserung schlecht gemacht und
deshalb lehnen wir gesetz ab
wer als cdu csu fraktion sind von anfang
an für weitaus wirksamere maßnahmen
eingetreten und das haben wir in unserem
antrag auch noch einmal aus formuliert
wir wollen eine ausweitung der
unterstützung auf alle kinderzuschlags
empfänger und bezieher kleinerer
einkommen
wir wollen eine jährliche anpassung des
wohngeldes an die energiekosten
eingebaut ins wohngeldgesetz so
vermeiden wir auch einen riesigen
regulierungs aufwand in den dann und
außerdem halten wir die senkung der
umsatzsteuer auf strom gas und fernwärme
lieferung für richtig und notwendig und
nicht zuletzt brauchen wir eine
härtefallregelung beispielsweise für
fernwärme kunden die mit extremen
preissteigerungen konfrontiert sind das
alles sind auch deshalb vernünftige
vorschläge weil ihr die höheren
energiepreise aktuell auf deutlich mehr
steuereinnahmen für den staat bedeuten
da ist es nur fair wenn der
finanzminister den dadurch in not
geratenen menschen etwas von diesen
mehreinnahmen zurückgibt
denn für alle menschen gilt eine warme
wohnung darf nicht zur schuldenfalle
werden
angesichts der immer weiter steigenden
energiepreise ist jetzt die zeit für
beherztes handeln
ich frage mich zur zeit wo bleibt
eigentlich bei allen ampel parteien der
gestaltungsanspruch mit dem sie vor
einem halben jahr noch auf wählerfang
gegangen sind ich sehe die wahlplakate
noch vor mir bei der spd hieß es olaf
scholz der kanzler für bezahlbares
wohnen
und bei den grünen war zu lesen zukunft
passiert nicht wir machen sie und bei
der fdp stand den dicken buchstaben nie
gab es mehr zu tun ja dann tun sie hier
auch endlich etwas und zweitens
spürbares und strukturelles für alle
betroffenen menschen erinnern
für bündnis 90 die grünen hat hanna
steinen oder jetzt das buch
[Applaus]
in liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
existenzangst
das ist was viele menschen in
deutschland gerade empfinden wenn sie an
die heizkostenabrechnung denken dass man
nachts aufwacht und vorsorge nicht
wieder einschläft das einem tagsüber die
angst im nacken sitzt weil man nicht
weiß wie man die energiekosten bezahlen
sollen um das zumindest in teilen zu
lindern beschließen wir heute den
heizkostenzuschuss
die energiepreise in den letzten monaten
stark gestiegen davon sind alle menschen
in deutschland betroffen
und trotzdem sind sie unterschiedlich
stark betroffen können ist
unterschiedlich gut wegstecken deswegen
haben sie uns den
koalitionsverhandlungen geeinigt den
heizkostenzuschuss
einzuführen um schnee die jenigen zu
unterstützen die besonders betroffen
sind
ministerin games hat den ersten entwurf
eingebracht wir haben jetzt nach der
anhörung noch zwei wichtige änderungen
vorgenommen
zum einen haben wir den
heizkostenzuschuss verdoppelt
für die vierköpfige familie bedeutet das
nun dass ihm 490 euro automatisch mit
dem nächsten oder übernächsten wohngeld
ausgezahlt werden für das rentnerehepaar
sind es 290 euro für die alleinstehende
frau 270 euro die automatisch auf dem
konto landen
außerdem haben wir dafür gesorgt dass
alle gruppen den zuschuss automatisch
ausbezahlt bekommen das hatten wir im
ersten gesetzentwurf noch anders da
haben wir auch in der ersten lesung
darüber diskutiert auch bafög beziehen
bekommen den autos automatisch damit
niemand auf der strecke bleibt war er
dass sie den antrag sich auszahlen muss
kann
ausgegangen
das bedeutet konkret die studentin der
meister bafög beziehen oder die person
die berufsausbildungsbeihilfe bekommt
bekommt automatisch
230 euro direkt über riefen davon
profitieren in meinem wahlkreis in
berlin mitte mehrere tausend menschen in
berlin gibt es 50.000 haushalte die
davon profitieren und deutschlandweit
mehr als zwei millionen menschen
das hat es schon dreimal reingerufen das
macht es nicht besser ja in deutschland
rund 80 millionen menschen das haben sie
ein paar mal gesagt habe ich gehört
genau ist vollkommen unstreitig trotzdem
muss man jetzt zielgerichtet helfen aber
gut das ist eine andere debatte
klar ist das ist nur der anfang es
müssen weitere entlastungen folgen wir
werden auch beim thema beim wohngeld
dafür sorgen dass es eine
klimakomponente gibt und da vorgehen als
ich komme schon zum schluss dass mein
als acht orten sind mein erstes gesetz
aber auch als ampel ein zu ersten das an
meine kollegen wehren hat da druck
daniel und meinem haushalt der andreas
automatisch für die gute zusammenarbeit
darf man denn mit
einer stange
gibt das hört sich die grünen im
deutschen bundestag auf sie reagieren
das haben jetzt einige der lieder übers
tieren die einen münzenmaier fdp
fraktion
sebastian münster hat jetzt das wort für
die afg fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren heizkosten explodieren
spritpreise gehen durch die decke
lebensmittelkosten plötzlich ein
vielfaches bald werden viele menschen in
unserem land vor der traurigen
entscheidung stehen ob sie sich eine
warme wohnung oder eine warme mahlzeit
leisten könnten und es sind nicht putins
panzer die verantwortlich für diese
kostensteigerung sind sondern der
angriffskrieg in der ukraine ist nur der
berühmte tropfen der auf ein längst voll
gelaufen es fast trifft es ist nämlich
ihre desaströse politik alle altparteien
die diese kostenexplosion ursächlich
herbeigeführt hat es sind die kosten
ihrer irrsinnigen energiewende die
unseren fleißigen bürgern den hals
abschnüren und nun von weiterungen
teuerungen durch den ukrainer krieg noch
gesteigert werden sie schütteln den kopf
aber schon einen monat vor dem krieg lag
die preissteigerung bei erdgas bei 32
prozent heizöl war sogar 52 prozent
teurer und ihre lösung ist jetzt also
ein einmaliger heizkostenzuschuss herr
kollege entschuldigung verstanden hat
sie haben wahrscheinlich vergessen dass
sie die maske wieder aussetzen müssen
bitteschön dankeschön und seal frau
staatssekretärin sie reden davon dass
dieser zuschuss ein beispiel für soziale
gerechtigkeit zwei schauen wir uns das
mal an wir haben es mehrfach gehört eine
million haushalte in deutschland
profitieren von diesen zuschuss 40
millionen haushalte in deutschland
bekommen gar nichts wenn das ein
beispiel für soziale gerechtigkeit ist
da muss ich ihnen sagen herzlichen
glückwunsch lieber spd sie haben
wirklich abgewirtschaftet ich habe heute
aus rheinland pfalz eine e mail von der
fleißigen frau bekommen die mir die
dramatik der preis explosion am eigenen
beispiel geschildert hat sie lebt in
einer drei zimmer wohnung in einem
zweifamilienhaus und sie zahlt bisher
110 euro für ihre gasheizungen pro monat
jetzt hat sie eine preiserhöhung
bekommen und muss bei
275 euro monatlich bezahlen 275 euro
monatlich diese frau ist massiv von der
teuerung betroffen und das problem ist
sie es nicht wohngeldberechtigt das
heißt ihr gesetzentwurf bringt dieser
dame exakt gar nichts sie bekommt 0 euro
und steht schlechter da wie je zuvor das
ist nicht gerecht meine damen und herren
das das gegenteil von gerechtigkeit
generell gilt für den zuschuss einen
heizkostenzuschuss der irgendwann im
sommer oder ich zitiere frau huber zum
ende des jahres ausgezahlt wird und
einmalig 250 euro beträgt das ist ein
tropfen auf den heißen stein der zu spät
ausgezahlt wird der zu gering angesetzt
ist und der für einen viel zu kleinen
empfängerkreis gedacht dass meine damen
und herren wir als auf die fraktion wir
vertreten einen anderen ansatz statt
almosen für wenige wollen wir eine
breite entlastung der bürger und
steuerzahler die sämtliche haushalte
erreicht und die dafür sorgt dass die
menschen wieder mehr geld in der tasche
haben bereits anfang november haben wir
mit mehreren antrag hier im deutschen
bundestag dafür gekämpft die staatlichen
abgaben auf energie zu senken aber
unsere sinnvollen ideen wurden von ihnen
allen abgelehnt deshalb fordern wir sie
heute noch einmal auf senken sie die
mehrwertsteuer auf strom gas und heizöl
vorübergehend auf null prozent
schaffen sie die co2 abgabe und die eeg
umlage ab senken sie die mehrwertsteuer
auf kraftstoffe auf null prozent
ergänzen sie das wohngeld um eine
dynamisiert energiekosten komponente und
helfen sie wohngeldempfängern dadurch
nicht nur einmalig sondern dauerhaft
und eines noch
angesichts millionenfacher altersarmut
in deutschland erhöhen sie den regelsatz
für empfänger von grundsicherung im
alter meine damen und herren all das
wären beispiele für echte soziale
gerechtigkeit und all das wäre momentan
mehr als angebracht aber hören sie doch
bitte endlich mal auch in allen
politikfeldern nur an problemen
herumzudoktern die sie selbst verursacht
haben das geld unserer steuerzahler
gehört in die taschen unserer bürger die
dieses land trotz katastrophaler
regierung und trotz widrigster umstände
jeden tag am laufen halten danke für
ihre aufmerksamkeit man dann
soweit sebastian münzenmaier aus der afg
hat hier aus einer e mail zitiert der
heute bekommen hat auf ihn folgt nun
sandra weser für die fdp-fraktion sie
ist vorsitzende des ausschusses für
wohnen stadtentwicklung bauwesen und
kommunen hier in dieser debatte zur
heizkostenzuschuss
[Applaus]
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wenn ich
mir so manche rede anhören da muss ich
ganz ehrlich sagen wo ist der kühle kopf
und vernünftige entscheidungen her zu
treffen also was man hier zum teil hört
bleibt mir persönlich wirklich die
spucke weg politische affekthandlungen
helfen hier nicht sondern hilft nur
zielgerichtetes handeln und sorry frau
könig alle ihre forderungen die sie
herstellen widersprechen sich in sich
der gestaltungsanspruch bei der cdu geht
hier wirklich gegen null und
wenn ich mir dann aus emotionaler
beschwörung von seiten der linken an
höre was knappheit am gas und heizöl
entsprechend später muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen sie müssen erstmal
erklären mit wessen geld um wem wir hier
eigentlich helfen und die liebe union
laut anklagen das hilft natürlich immer
auch von den eigenen fehlern abzulenken
ja und unangenehme fragen den kann man
zwar auch ausreichen aber eine frage die
kann ich ihnen nicht ersparen weil das
ist nämlich die frage wer hat denn den
essen 16 jahren versäumt deutschland
unabhängiger von russischem gas und von
erdöl zu machen das waren sie doch wir
haben doch heute machen sich darin uns
an der die versorgung
haben meldet auch alle gekommen die
lösungsvorschläge die fehlt mir
definitiv ganz klar ist massive
preissteigerung bei gas von öl sind eine
direkte folge von dem zerstörerischen
krieg putins der im moment auf
ukrainischem boden macht und da hilft
auch kein jammern und kein wunschdenken
da hilft im prinzip nur kurzfristig
abrufen und mittelfristig unabhängig
machen
ja aber der haid und jetzt kommen wir
mal zu ihnen und der heizkostenzuschuss
ist ja nur ein baustein von einem großen
entlastungspaket und wenn wir von ihren
mehrwertsteuer fangen das leben sprechen
dann müssen sie auch bedenken dass in
vielen anderen bereichen die mehrwert
stellen nur ein durchlaufender posten
ist das hilft keinem unternehmer keine
selbstständigen keine mittelständler
es kann nicht alle probleme lösen aber
der heizkostenzuschuss er hilft
unbürokratisch er hilft schnell und er
hilft zielgenau und gerade genau bei den
menschen die am härtesten betroffen sind
und es nicht mehr aber es ist auch nicht
weniger und wo linke und die union nur
probleme beschreiben das 16 wir nämlich
hier konkrete dinge um und da sind wir
nämlich beim gestaltungswillen lieber
afd die sich gerade etwas aufregt der
heizkostenzuschuss ist eine kurzfristige
notfallmaßnahme und zwei dient sie zur
abfederung von sozialer härte und damit
erreichen wir nämlich jetzt hier genau
drei ziele wir helfen unkompliziert und
deswegen wird das geld auch ohne
umständliche antragsverfahren
automatisch ausgezahlt und wenn man frau
könig hier folgen würden würden wir
wahrscheinlich erst next ist ja
überhaupt die gesetzesänderungen durch
haben so kompliziert ist
und die bafög empfänger bekommen so
auffällig unbürokratisch auch das war
uns wichtig dass da direkte auszahlung
erfüllt
zweitens fern sind schnell mit der
heutigen verabschieden sorgen wir dafür
dass die menschen ihr geld auf dem konto
haben und angesichts der gestiegenen
preise haben wir diese woche ja auch
nochmal entsprechenden
heizkostenzuschuss verdoppelt und
drittens
wir helfen hier sehr gezielt das ist
sozial aber es ist vor allen dingen auch
verantwortungsvoll im umgang mit dem
geld der steuerzahler
weitere maßnahmen zur entlastung der
bürger sind vereinbart und werden auch
folgen und ich nenne ja ich nenne nur
ein paar eg umlage abschaffen zb
steuerliche entlastung der mittelschicht
haben wir hier wir haben die erhöhung
der pendlerpauschale und es gibt noch
viele viele mehr also regen sie sich
nicht so auf nun gibt politische
parteien deren lösungsvorschläge für all
diese probleme natürlich sich auf ein
prinzip reduzieren bevor dann überall
und mehr geld für alle und die
ergebnisse dieser politik lassen sich
wunderbar in argentinien auch beobachten
da haben wir nämlich ein trauriger
regelmäßigkeit ein staatsbankrott was
mich um ehrlich zu sein stück weiter
überraschen liebe union das sind die
forderungen von ihnen weil diese
mittlerweile von den linken worte nicht
mehr zu unterscheiden ja die mir wie mir
scheint entdecken trat herr dobrindt und
herr merz angesichts der energiekrise
ihre liebe für sozialpolitische
wirtschafts prinzipien und dann muss ich
auch mal fragen was kochst du deine
umfangreicher forderungskatalog
jeden steuerzahler
wie soll denn die gegenfinanzierung
funktionieren wollen wir jetzt
steuererhöhungen wollen wir die energie
unternehmen verstaatlichen wollen wann
schuldenexplosion und dann was bleibt am
letzten endes in der mitte der
gesellschaft als entlastung davon übrig
weil wenn man jetzt im prinzip folgt
dann ist das also linke tasche rechte
tasche energiepreise staatlich
subventionieren
und zur ehrlichkeit gehört eben auch
dazu die politik verteilt das geld das
die bürgerinnen und bürger
erwirtschaftet haben und deswegen stehen
wir vor einem verantwortungsvollen
umgang mit dem geld der steuerzahler
aber auch verantwortungsvoll für
kommende generationen das bedeutet wir
helfen bezieht und unbürokratisch da wo
es nötig ist aber zugleich verwahrte
halten wir auch die verhältnismäßigkeit
1 denn der heizkostenzuschuss beschließt
dem wir heute beschließen ist immer eine
kurzfristige maßnahme und ich hoffe der
nächsten debatte können wir auch mal
über nachhaltige themen notieren wie die
sanierung von häusern im einzelnen in
deutschland ich bedanke mich im
vergangenen winter hatten laut
statistischem bundesamt 7,4 millionen
menschen in deutschland nicht genügend
geld um ihre wohnung angemessen zu
heizen so schreibt es die links fraktion
in ihrem antrag den sie eingereicht hat
deswegen fordert sie unter anderem eine
einmalzahlung
für die linke spricht jetzt wissen
meine fraktion die fraktion die linke
hat schon im november einen keiner soll
frieren plan von der bundesregierung
gefordert doch lange ist nichts passiert
doch endlich hat unser druck gewürgt und
das ist gut so meine damen und herren
was jetzt vorlegen der
heizkostenzuschuss ist ein schritt in
die richtige richtung und darum werden
wir als linke im unterschied zu den
parteien hier auf der rechten seite des
hauses auch zustimmen aber es hat zu
lange gedauert und die anhörung am
montag im ausschuss hat auch deutlich
gemacht dass dieser schritt ein erster
schritt ist aber nicht ausreichend und
das weitere maßnahmen erfolgen müssen
und dazu werden wir ihn gleich noch
vorschläge unterbreiten und jeder fragt
sich doch wenn die ampel in der lage ist
von einem tag auf den anderen 100
milliarden euro komitee rische
aufrüstung bereit zu stellen warum
dauert es lange wenn man die ärmsten in
unserer gesellschaft unterstützen soll
das können wir nicht akzeptieren meine
damen und herren wir
sagen sie müssen endlich mehr soziale
wärme wagen meine damen und herren ich
hatte das statistische bundesamt gefragt
wie viele menschen zu wenig geld haben
um ihre wohnung ausreichend zu heizen
im jahr 2020 waren das 7,4 millionen
menschen also fast zehn prozent der
bevölkerung das ist doch in unserem
reichen land nicht hinnehmbar meine
damen und herren und diese tag wird
angesichts der aktuellen preis explosion
wahrscheinlich noch dramatisch ansteigen
die lehrstellen aus der anhörung haben
wir in unserem entschließungsantrag den
wir ihnen heute zur zustimmung vorlegen
noch einmal zusammengefasst und ich
werde einige punkte benennen es wurde
ganz deutlich
nochmal gesagt auch vom parität dass die
hartz-iv-sätze endlich deutlich
angehoben werden müssen der parität da
sagt
678 euro und wir finden dass es eine
wichtige und richtige formel 1 sollte
das wohngeld muss endlich auf der basis
der motor warm miete gezahlt werden und
wir sagen auch strom und das sperren
müssen endlich verboten werden es ist
unmenschlich menschen im dunkeln und in
der kälte sitzen zu lassen haben
von der preis explosion sind natürlich
nicht nur menschen mit kleinen und
mittleren einkommen besprochen wir
hatten heute ja mehrere
tagesordnungspunkte dazu und auch diese
menschen müssen entlastet werden und wir
wollen nicht im unterschied zur fdp die
großen konzerne weiter subventionieren
sondern wir wollen endlich eine
staatliche preiskontrolle und eine
staatliche preisregulierung die eu hat
uns damit auch ein mittel in die hand
gegeben dass es möglich das können wir
umsetzen und ich fordere sie auf fassen
sie endlich diese beschlüsse damit alle
in unserem land in energiesicherheit
würde ich reden können vielen dank
soweit die haushaltspolitische
sprecherin der linksfraktion im
deutschen gäste sind
ob sie folgten martin gegen rouven für
die s p definition er ist im mitglied im
ausschuss für stadtentwicklung bauwesen
und kommunion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die alle
schauen mit sorge auf die entwicklungen
in der ukraine und wir sind in gedanken
bei den menschen dort die gerade
unerträgliches leid erfahren im
vergleich dazu sind unsere probleme
gering die finanziellen folgen des
krieges die kriegen wir aber auch hier
zu spüren viele menschen leiden unter
den explodierenden energiepreisen ob es
um es auch nochmal hier deutlich zu
sagen die kleineren einkommen desto
größer wird da die belastung
deshalb war uns als ampel fraktionen
auch ganz klar dass der
heizkostenzuschuss deutlich höher
ausfallen muss um die menschen schnell
und spürbar zu entlasten
eine einmalige zahlung von 135 euro wie
es vorgesehen waren singlehaushalte wäre
an der stelle zu wenig gewesen von
anfang an haben wir versprochen die
energiepreisentwicklung
zu beobachten wir haben gesagt bei einer
weiteren zuspitzung zögern wir nicht
nochmal nachzusteuern genau das haben
wir getan und die beträge für alle
zielgruppen nicht nur deutlich erhöht
sondern verdoppelt und das ist ein
großer erfolg der ampel koalition
damit folgen die den empfehlungen der
sachverständigen die vergangenen montag
in der anhörung im ausschuss zu wort
gekommen sind und einstimmig auch eine
erhöhung empfohlen haben unterm strich
werden nun über zwei millionen menschen
von dem heizkostenzuschuss
profitieren allein lebende menschen mit
wohngeld zugehalten 270 euro
zweipersonenhaushalte 350 euro und für
jede weitere person jeweils 70 euro
studierende auszubildende und andere
berechtigte bekommen pauschal 130 euro
das hilft ganz konkret und deutlich
liebe kollegen und kollegen
auch bei der ursprünglich vorgesehenen
antragsfrist für junge menschen in
ausbildung und studium haben wir noch
einmal nachgebessert wenn sie jetzt von
studierenden oder auszubilden und
gefragt werden wo sie den
heizkostenzuschuss beantragen können
dann ist hier die gute nachricht das
sind antrag nicht mehr notwendig ist
denn die ampel weniger bürokratie wagen
und schnell und unkompliziert helfen
ich freue mich sehr dass wir gemeinsam
mit den fraktionen der grünen und der
fdp diese nachbesserungen vorgenommen
haben ganz herzlichen dank an dieser
stelle an die kollegen kollegen der
fraktion
klar ist aber auch dass der
heizkostenzuschuss keine dauerhafte
lösung darstellt es ist eine
kurzfristige maßnahme die am stärksten
betroffenen mit den steigenden
heizkosten nicht alleine zu als
dauerhafte entlastungsmaßnahmen
beispielsweise werden wir die im
koalitionsvertrag verabredete
klimakomponente beim wohngeld
vorantreiben so wichtig der
heizkostenzuschuss auch ist wir müssen
auch die belastung von familien im blick
behalten die keinen anspruch auf
wohngeld haben
dafür hat die bundesregierung und wird
weitere entlastungen angekündigt die wir
schnell auf den weg bringen werden
wichtig ist dass die maßnahmen zum einen
zielgerichtet sind und zum anderen nicht
unseren klimaschutzzielen entgegen
sprechen setzen wir falsche anreize
schießen wir uns nur selbst ins knie
denn wir wollen doch so schnell wie
möglich raus aus der abhängigkeit von
energieimporten indem wir den
klimaschutz und den ausbau von
erneuerbaren energien massiv
vorantreiben
neben ausgleichszahlungen müssen wir
auch darüber sprechen wo und wie wir
energie einsparen können das macht uns
nicht nur unabhängiger von russischen
gas fördern schützt insbesondere auch
menschen mit niedrigem einkommen vor
steigenden energiepreisen denn wer wohnt
denn in schlecht sanierten schlecht
gedämmten wohnungen mit veralteten
heizanlagen er nicht der
vorstandsvorsitzende sondern häufig
menschen die auf jeden euro achten
müssen unsere aufgabe ist es also den
menschen zuversicht zu geben dass sie
durch energieeffizientes sanieren auf
dauer entlastet und nicht belastet
werden klar ist effizienz und
bezahlbarkeit müssen hand in hand gehen
und dafür werden wir sorgen herzlichen
dank
und wir uns das sprechen sie ist
mitglied der cdu csu fraktion auch von
der cdu csu fraktion gibt es einen
entschließungsantrag in dem die fraktion
schreibt dass die idee dieses
heizkostenzuschuss ist zwar richtig sei
aber die maßnahme zu bürokratisch und
nicht umfassend genug
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen liebe kollegin
weser auch die fdp hat in der
vergangenheit mal für steuersenkungen
gestanden und nichts anderes fordern wir
als unionsfraktion deswegen fand ich das
jetzt schon sehr spannend was sie
vorgetragen haben und wenn sie die
regierung die vorgänger regierung
kritisieren würde ich auch bitte darum
werben dann auch zu differenzieren
nämlich erwähnt sie meinen die spd oder
die union und die csu auch dabei auch da
schimpfen sie ja vor allem auf die union
aber wir haben auch nicht alleine
regiert ja das thema heute
ist das thema der heizkosten und egal wo
wir hinschauen erleben die menschen in
unserem land preissteigerungen
spätestens an der tankstelle werden sie
wahrgenommen wenn die großen
anzeigentafel mit preisen von über 2
euro pro liter sprit leuchten und dann
geht es eben auch weiter mit dem thema
strom und dem thema lebensmittel und
teilweise noch im nebel so hat man den
eindruck bleiben hingegen die massiven
kostensteigerungen im bereich der
heizkosten und ich habe große sorge dass
es hier wirklich ein böses erwachen gibt
spätestens bei der nächsten
nebenkostenabrechnung für mieterinnen
und mieter deshalb ist der verbesserte
gesetzentwurf zum heizkostenzuschuss
grundsätzlich zu begrüßen mit dem
heizkostenzuschuss werden aber nur die
kostensteigerungen für energie aus den
vergangenen jahr halbwegs gedeckt und
für die zukunft bleibt die
bundesregierung weiter eine antwort
schuldig deshalb haben wir als unions
fraktion auch einen entschließungsantrag
eingebracht der beispiel die höhe des
wohngeldes an die energiekosten koppelt
und jährlich dynamisiert werden soll so
wie wir überhaupt gewollt hätten dass
die regelungen in die stamm gesetze
übernommen werden um bürokratie zu
vermeiden die auszahlungen auch zu
beschleunigen und nachhaltig auf
preisentwicklungen reagieren zu können
in den anhörungen und da waren ja die
kollegen auch der ampel dabei wurde zu
recht kritisiert dass es drei neue
verordnungen in jedem einzelnen
bundesland braucht um dieses gesetz
umzusetzen
deshalb sind die nachbesserungen im
änderungsantrag die von der ambri kamen
auch wichtig aber wenn selbst die
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
der spd die kollegin verena hubert davon
spricht dass die auszahlung bis zum ende
des jahres dauern könnten würde ich das
dann als eine glatte themaverfehlung
bezeichnen denn
wer schnell helfen will und da bin ich
wieder bei den kollegen von der fdp und
ich werbe ausdrücklich dafür dabei eben
nicht nur transfer leistungsbezieher zu
berücksichtigen muss runter mit den
steuern muss runter mit den abgaben so
wie wir es auch eben in unserem antrag
geschrieben haben denn was machen die
menschen mit kleinen und mittleren
einkommen die knapp über der
einkommensgrenze für das wohngeld liegen
die bleiben voll auf den kosten sitzen
dabei müssten auch sie schon jetzt zu
rücklagen bilden um die rechnungen für
die steigenden heizkosten zu zahlen und
auch die vermieterseite kann nicht
unberücksichtigt bleiben denn bevor
kostensteigerungen beim mieter ankommen
muss der vermieter und das sind eben zu
zwei drittel immer noch kleinst
vermieter bei denen die vermietete
wohnung auch teil der anders
altersvorsorge ist in vorleistung gehen
deshalb reicht die entlastung von zwei
millionen menschen bei weitem noch nicht
aus es reicht nicht nur
transferleistungsempfänger zu
berücksichtigen die entlastung muss
breiter angelegt werden auch dazu haben
wir einen antrag als union heute
vormittag ins parlament eingebracht
indem wir die unternehmen in unserem
land in uns in den fokus genommen haben
auch da wieder die fdp sie waren auch
mal vertreter eben der kleinen
handwerker die auch jetzt sehr gebeutelt
sind durch die gestiegenen durch die
gestiegenen preise aber eben
beispielsweise auch die stark unter
druck geraten die glasindustrie in
meiner heimat und ich bin sehr dankbar
dass wir da mit dem
wirtschaftsministerium mit dem
staatssekretär im gespräch sein dürfen
denn da brennt vor ort und es ist geht
um arbeitsplätze und es lässt uns nicht
kalt und natürlich gilt auch das eine
tun ohne das andere zu lassen deswegen
ist es auch richtig das kartellamt
einzuschalten aber eben nicht nur beim
thema benzin aber es ist einfach nicht
zu vermitteln wenn der staat an den
steigenden energiepreisen mit verdient
und deshalb erwarten die menschen in
unserem land zu recht dass sie auf die
mehreinnahmen durch gestiegene
energiepreise verzichten deshalb liefern
sie sei wahnsinnig und dieser
gesetzentwurf ist wichtig aber er ist
eben auch eine vertragliche kollegen
[Applaus]
bundestags vizepräsidentin katrin göring
eckardt hat hier heute schon mehrmals
auf die redezeit hingewiesen denn auch
das sei gesagt sie und petra pau die
müssen hier heute die ganzen zungen
leiten denn im präsidium ist auch koyo
vorherrschend und so müssen diese beiden
frauen hier als übrig gebliebene alle
sitzungen seiten julia verlinkten
spricht jetzt die stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der grünen im
bundestag
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
dass wir hier und heute den
heizkostenzuschuss verabschieden können
das ist das ergebnis von guter und
konstruktiver zusammenarbeit in der
ampel ein expliziter dank gilt hierbei
auch insbesondere der frau ministerin
gleiwitz und ihrem haus gehen wir doch
noch einmal einen schritt zurück warum
ist dieser zuschuss überhaupt notwendig
geworden unsere energieversorgung ist in
eine preisspirale geraten die zuletzt
mit dem furchtbaren und
völkerrechtswidrigen überfall von putin
auf die ukraine ihre spitze erreicht hat
in unserem land wird für die
wärmeerzeugung immer noch viel die kohle
öl und erdgas gebraucht das ist nicht
nur schlecht für das klima sondern auch
für die drohende nebenkostenabrechnungen
der menschen in den vergangenen jahren
ist einfach viel zu wenig von der
unionsgeführten bundesregierung passiert
und schneller von dieser
klimaschädlichen und teuren abhängigkeit
der fossilen loszukommen und das
innerlich jetzt
es geht dabei um energie einsparen und
umstellung auf erneuerbare erzeugte
wärme denn oft zahlen die menschen die
am wenigsten geld haben besonders viel
fürs heizen weil sie in den gebäuden
leben die am meisten schlucken und damit
sie von den hohen heizkosten aus diesem
winter nicht erdrückt werden haben wir
als ampel diesen heizkostenzuschuss
zügig auf den weg gebracht das ist gut
und das ist richtig meine damen und
herren
doch damit sind wir noch lange nicht
fertig die wichtigste maßnahme um
dauerhaft heizkosten zu senken sind
investitionen
investitionen in gebäudesanierung
investitionen um energie nachhaltig
einzusparen jeder euro in bessere
gebäude der zahlt sich bei geringeren
heizkosten aus daher unterstützen wir
die hauseigentümerinnen dafür braucht es
neben förderprogrammen für
gebäudesanierung auch ein
zukunftsfähiges gebäude energie gesetz
und das werden wir noch in diesem jahr
novellieren da sitzt das ministerium von
robert habeck bereits dran
beim bau von neuen gebäuden da könnt ihr
sofort auf fossile heizungen verzichten
und wir können auch im gebäudebestand
schnelle fortschritte erzielen noch in
diesem jahr wir brauchen dafür eine
offensive bei der gebäudesanierung und
beim heizungstausch und ich bin dem
haushaltsausschuss wirklich sehr dankbar
dass sie hier in dieser woche noch
einmal kurzfristig weitere mittel in
milliarden höhe zur verfügung gestellt
haben
eine zusätzliche chance
eine zusätzliche chance bietet die
serielle sanierung mit dieser innovation
können wir noch vor dem nächsten winter
einen wichtigen beitrag für eine
vielzahl von wohnungen leisten
natürlich haben wir uns viel vorgenommen
aber wir sind als ampel nicht angetreten
um den status quo zu erhalten
wir wollen dinge bewegen und soziale
gerechtigkeit innovation und klimaschutz
voranbringen also lassen sie uns
gemeinsam daran so konstruktiv und
erfolgreich arbeiten denn zu bezahlbaren
hohen gehören auch niedrige nebenkosten
vielen dank
und da kann
man in dieser debatte zum
heizkostenzuschuss und das ist lina
seite für die spd fraktion
sie sitzt im ausschuss für umwelt
naturschutz nukleare sicherheit und
verbraucherschutz
und das hier ist ihre erste rede im
deutschen bundestag
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die lage von menschen mit
niedrigem einkommen spitzt sich in
zeiten steigender energiepreise immer
weiter zu über die dringende
notwendigkeit von entlastung wurde von
seinen vor rednerinnen und vorrednern
bereits viel gesagt deshalb führen wir
den heizkostenzuschuss ein als eine
erste entlastungsmaßnahmen
weitere werden folgen es sollte ihnen
liebe kollegin kollegen der
unionsfraktion eigentlich auch bewusst
sein
über eine kuppe haben wir hier in der
debatte noch nicht so viel gesprochen
und mir scheint wir sprechen über diese
gruppe in dem haus sowieso relativ wenig
das sind junge menschen die befinden
sich seit über zwei jahren in einer
ausnahmesituation
es gibt zum beispiel studierende die im
vierten semester sind und ihre
universität ihre hochschule noch nie von
innen gesehen die ihre kommilitoninnen
und kommilitonen nur von kacheln am
laptop kennen und diese ihr studium ganz
sicher anders vorgestellt haben mit
vielen von ihnen habe ich gesprochen und
war beeindruckt dass sie trotz der
eigenen hohen belastung der chor ohne
einschränkung mit großer solidarität und
vernunft mitgetragen haben aber auf all
diese psychischen belastung türen sich
nun noch finanzielle sorgen die
dramatisch gestiegenen energiepreise
verschärfen die situation insbesondere
auch durch das studium im home office
und jetzt verstehen sie mich bitte nicht
falsch alle sorgen werden wir den jungen
menschen in ausbildung mit dem
heizkostenzuschuss natürlich nicht geben
können was wir ihnen aber nehmen können
gerade denen mit besonders niedrigem
einkommen ist der weiter steigende
finanzielle druck
der heizkostenzuschuss für bezieher von
bafög aufstiegs bafög und
ausbildungsbeihilfe soll 230 euro
betragen und damit doppelt so viel wie
ursprünglich vorgesehen er wird direkt
und zeitnah ausgezahlt denn wir wollen
mit dem heizkostenzuschuss
entlasten und nicht weiter belasten
deshalb wird der heizkostenzuschuss
direkt aufs konto überwiesen ohne dass
dafür ein antrag erforderlich ist wenn
wir diesen heizkostenzuschuss heute zu
beschließen dann unterstützen wir nicht
nur die wohngeld empfängerinnen und
empfänger sondern auch mehr als eine
halbe million junge menschen die ihre
ausbildung ohne finanzielle
rückendeckung der eltern absolvieren
liebe kolleginnen kollegen von jungen
menschen haben wir doch in den letzten
beiden jahren erwartet das ist schon
irgendwie zurechtkommen mit all den
veränderungen einschränkungen ihres
alltags und oftmals mussten sie einfach
funktioniert die korona demi hat uns
aber auch gezeigt wie verwundbar hat
diese gruppe sein kann deshalb entlasten
wir sie jetzt schnell und unkompliziert
und deshalb berücksichtigen wir sie beim
heizkostenzuschuss vielen dank
herzlichen dank damit schließt sich die
aussprache und wir kommen zur abstimmung
über den von den fraktionen von spd
bündnis 90/die grünen und fdp
eingebrachten gesetzentwurf zur
gewährung eines einmaligen
heizkostenzuschuss aufgrund stark
gestiegener energiekosten der ausschuss
für wohnen stadtentwicklung bauwesen und
kommunen empfiehlt unter buchstabe a
seiner beschlussempfehlung aufdruck
sarrazin 65 den gesetzentwurf der
fraktion der spd bündnis 90 die grünen
fdp auf drucksache 689 in der ausschuss
fassung anzunehmen ich bitte jetzt
diejenigen die dem gesetzentwurf und der
ausschuss fassung zustimmen wollte um
das handzeichen
vielen dank wer stimmt dagegen
danke sehr enthaltungen
vielen dank der gesetzentwurf in zweiter
beratung angenommen zugestimmt haben die
spd bündnis 90 die grünen fdp und die
linke dagegen die unionsfraktion die
fraktion der afg hat sich enthalten
dritte beratung und sturz abstimmung ich
bitte diejenigen die zustimmen wollen
sich zu erheben
danke sehr wer möchte dagegen stimmen
vielen dank und wer enthält sich
herzlichen dank damit ist der
gesetzentwurf in dritter beratung
angenommen mit dem gleichen
stimmenverhältnis wie vorher also das
bedeutet dass der heizkostenzuschuss für
menschen mit weniger einkommen
verdoppelt wird zu dem was ich geplant
war dafür gibt es auch hier applaus rund
21 millionen bürger sollen nach an haben
die bundesregierung davon profitieren
enthaltungen
jetzt ist hier die abstimmung über den
entschließungsantrag der union der
abgelehnt wurde in dem unter anderem
gefordert wurde dass die
unterschiedlichen belastungen beim
heizen stärker abgebildet werden müssen
jetzt gibt es hier noch eine abstimmung
über einen entschließungsantrag der
linksfraktion in dem die linksfraktion
wie von gesine lötzsch auch in der
debatte erklärt ein einen plan erfordert
unter anderen soll das wohngeld komplett
reformiert werden es soll ein umstieg
auf ein warmmieten system geben
und nun sind wir damit in dieser debatte
bei der letzten abstimmung da geht es um
einen antrag der fraktion die linken in
dem sie sich auch auf das gleiche thema
bezieht und in dem sie unter anderem
fordert auch dass wohnwert auf basis der
brutto war miete zu zahlen und eine
steuerreform
fordert so das vermögen stärker belastet
werden
das nicht der fall dann ist diese
beschlussempfehlung angenommen mit der
mit gegenstimmen aus der fraktion die
linke alle anderen haben dafür gestimmt
ich hoffe jetzt auf den
tagesordnungspunkt nummer 12 beratung
des antrags der fraktion der cdu/csu mit
dem titel potenziale nutzen inklusive
arbeitswelt stärken das ist ein arbeiter
der unionsfraktion in dem die
unionsfraktion 20 maßnahmen
aufzählt in mit den menschen mit
behinderungen besser in den arbeitsmarkt
integriert werden sollen unter anderem
fordert die fraktion inklusions berater
bei den kammern und verbänden aber zb
auch ein förderprogramm für eine
barrierefreie
digitale
infrastruktur das ist unter anderem weil
es anzeichen dafür gibt dass während der
korona pandemie sich die jobsituation
für menschen mit behinderung noch einmal
deutlich verschlechtert hat so sieht ist
zumindest der behindertenbeauftragte der
bundesregierung
jürgen dusel und hat gesagt dass er
davon ausgeht dass von der erholung auch
das arbeitsmarkt nach der pandemie die
menschen mit schwerbehinderung erst ganz
zum schluss profitieren werden wilfried
eggers spricht als erstes für die
unionsfraktion sehr geehrte frau
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren den haben betrachters ukraine
krieges es ist sicherlich nicht leicht
über andere themen zu diskutieren aber
deswegen bin ich umso dankbarer dass wir
heute über die teilhabe von behinderten
menschen am arbeitsleben diskutieren und
debattieren können
bei die sehr geehrten damen und herren
was haben der barrierefreie umbau von
fahrzeugen ein cateringservice für
kita-kinder
holzspielzeug
kaffeegeschirr eine softwarelösung für
den für ein abrechnungssystem in einem
mittelständischen unternehmen gemeinsam
alle diese produkte und dienstleistungen
wäre nicht denkbar ohne die arbeit von
menschen mit behinderungen ihre
tätigkeit in werkstätten für behinderte
menschen oder inklusions unternehmen in
unternehmen auf dem ersten arbeitsmarkt
es muss ja nicht unbedingt gleich das
dax unternehmen sap sein das seit vielen
jahren vorreiter bei der beschäftigung
von menschen mit behinderungen vor allen
dingen mit autismus syndrom will ist es
kann auch ein kleinunternehmen sein wie
zum beispiel ein autohaus aus meinem
wahlkreis dass fahrzeuge umbaut in einem
barrierefreien zustand für menschen mit
behinderung unser ziel ist es
möglichst viele menschen mit behinderung
in den ersten arbeitsmarkt zu vermitteln
dann das problem ist nicht nur dass mehr
menschen mit behinderung arbeitslos sind
als menschen ohne behinderung sondern
auch dass sie länger arbeitslos sind
diese probleme müssen wir angehen und
dabei alle pfeiler des inklusiven
arbeitsmarkt wie inklusions betriebe
einrichtungen für die berufliche
rehabilitation
oder werkstätten für behinderte menschen
zu fördern und vor allem die übergänge
zwischen den einrichtungen und hin zum
ersten arbeitsmarkt zu verbessern als
regierungsfraktion der letzten
legislaturperioden haben wir hierzu
einiges auf den weg gebracht es ist gut
dass wir mittlerweile einheitliche
ansprechstellen für unternehmen für
arbeitgeber haben die jetzt aber in die
fläche gebracht werden müssen damit sie
eben auch die unternehmen begleiten
können menschen mit behinderungen auch
zu beschäftigen die bih hat zur
umsetzung der gesetzlich des
gesetzlichen auftrags
handlungsempfehlungen entwickelt aber
ich erwarte dass die bundesregierung
hier nicht nur auf die integrationsämter
und ihrer berichterstattung verlässt
sondern auch selbst eine aktive rolle
einnimmt eine bundesweite strategie und
auch einen zeitlichen fahrplan
entwickelt einen flickenteppich
einen flickenteppich
beratungsangebote dass es am ende nicht
geben die über 900 inklusions betriebe
leisten einen wichtigen beitrag als teil
des ersten arbeitsmarktes und zugleich
als brücke dorthin auch unabhängig von
der pandemie benötigen sie aber eine
sichere finanzielle basis der von
jährige der von der regierungskoalition
hat dem ersten oktober 2022 geplante
mindestlohn von 12 euro ist auch von dem
inklusions unternehmen zu tragen die
derzeitigen an die firmen gewährten
zuwendungen wachsen allerdings nicht
automatisch mit das muss gewährleistet
sein ebenso muss auch die umsatzsteuer
thematik die ja schon eine längere
thematik ist geregelt werden es ist auch
gut dass wir vor einigen jahren das
budget für arbeit und das budget für
ausbildung eingeführt haben und gerade
dort zuletzt mit dem teilhabe stärkung
des gesetz- punktuell noch einmal
nachgebessert haben doch wir alle wissen
die instrumente werden weiterhin viel zu
wenig genutzt und hier machen in unserem
antrag vorschläge wie man diese wichtige
brücke in den arbeitsmarkt attraktiver
gestalten kann zb durch die aufhebung
der begrenzung der lohnkosten zuschusses
beim budget für arbeit die erweiterung
des budgets für ausbildung auf die
inklusions betriebe und einrichtungen
der beruflichen rehabilitation
und diese instrumente durch eine
informations und schulungs kampagne
bekannter zu machen doch es wird auch
weiterhin menschen geben die den weg aus
den werkstätten hin auf den ersten
arbeitsmarkt nicht schaffen oder auch
nicht gehen wollen diese menschen
brauchen ein entgelt dass ihre arbeit
würdigt und den werkstätten finanziell
finanzierbar ist gleichzeitig weiß ich
aber auch aus vielen gesprächen mit den
werkstattbeschäftigten wie wichtig ihnen
ist dass sie ihre schutzrechte behalte
ich bin gespannt welche lösungen das
forschungsvorhaben für das werkstatt
entgelt hier zu unterbreiten wird wir
haben als cdu fraktion bereits in der
letzten legislaturperiode ein modell auf
den weg gelegt mit dem zumindest die
problematik der erhöhung des
grundbedarfs für die
werkstattbeschäftigten
abgefedert werden kann es ist auch gut
dass sich in der kommune pandemie
berufsbildungswerke und
berufsförderungswerk oder werkstätten
für behinderte menschen auf den weg
gemacht haben ihre leistungen auf
digitale angebote umzustellen hier hat
sich schnell gezeigt welchen mehrwert
die digitalisierung für die teilhabe von
menschen mit behinderung hat doch auch
aus dem austausch mit außerbetrieblichen
bildungseinrichtungen weiß ich dass man
sich dort mehr unterstützung für die
digitalisierung wünscht als union teilen
wir daher die meinung dass wir einen
eine art digital packt schule 2.0
benötigen ein förderprogramm für
barrierefreie digitale angebote in
außerbetrieblichen bildungseinrichtung
passt also sollte zusammenfassend zielen
inklusive arbeitsmarktpolitik der
nächsten jahre sein dass bedarf vor
allem mehr kooperation mehr ansprache
und eine stärkung der digitalen teilhabe
um die potenziale von beschäftigten mit
behinderung zu nutzen hierzu bietet
unser antrag konstruktive vorschläge ich
freue mich auf die beratungen vielen
dank
erst redet hier in der debatte zum
antrag der
unionsfraktion zum thema inklusive
arbeitswelt von wilfried eggers war das
kapital ii spielt jetzt für die spd ist
der beauftragte für die belange
behinderter menschen seiner fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sagt jetzt erst
mal etwas außergewöhnliches ich möchte
mich bei der union tatsächlich bedanken
aber nicht für diesen antrag nämlich
dass sie in der opposition sind weil sie
ermöglichen jetzt tatsächliche teilhabe
für menschen mit behinderung in der
gemeinschaft war es gibt ja auch in
diesem haus läuft ein phänomen ich
möchte ihnen das mal näher erläutern
wenn man er hinkommt ist es immer so
wenn sie in der opposition sind
entdecken sie plötzlich
arbeitsmarktpolitik und sozialpolitik
für menschen mit behinderung und deshalb
vielen vielen dank dass sie in der
opposition sind aber
aber ein paar worte möchte ich natürlich
auch zu ihren antrag erzählen
menschen mit autismus in dax-unternehmen
sind ein schönes beispiel für gelungene
inklusion in die arbeitswelt aber meiner
meinung nach auch ein sehr gutes
beispiel aber nicht immer unbedingt das
beispiel regen müssen wir aber besonders
über menschen mit psychischen
erkrankungen menschen mit
altersbedingten und oder geistigen
behinderungen was für mich besonders
wichtig ist auch über die menschen zu
reden die komplexere behinderungen haben
dort liegen nämlich die besonderen
herausforderungen
und jetzt ist ja auch so zu viele
unternehmen werden ihrer verantwortung
nicht gerecht
inklusion zu ermöglichen aus ihrem
antrag aber habe ich herausgelesen dass
das oftmals er den menschen mit
behinderung und ihren fähigkeiten
zugeschrieben werden dass das nicht
möglich ist ich sage ihnen aber ganz
klar wir brauchen nicht unternehmens
optimierte menschen mit behinderung wir
brauchen menschlichere unternehmen die
die bedarfe der menschen mit
behinderungen erkennen und diese auch
fördern können nämlich darlegte auftrag
wichtig ist doch
wichtig ist doch ich glaube man darf
einen aspekt nicht vernachlässigen ist
dass es besondere erfordernisse hier
gibt nämlich in der förderung und
weiterentwicklung der persönlichkeit und
des selbstwertgefühls
damit menschen mit behinderung nicht
immer das gefühl vermittelt bekommt eine
last für die gesellschaft zu sein ich
kann ihnen aber auch als mensch aus der
praxis der jetzt noch bis vor vier
monate in einer einrichtung für menschen
mit behinderung gearbeitet hat berichten
manchmal lohnt sich ein blick auf und
ein vertiefter blick in die
einrichtungen und nicht nur im wahlkampf
veranstaltungen mal dort präsent zu sein
sie haben in ihrem antrag sie haben in
ihrem antrag darüber gesprochen dass das
die werkstätten einen ort für förderung
sei das stimmt aber ich frage sie
einblick in die werkstätten verordnung
sagt doch bei einem personalschlüssel
von 1 zu 12 für die betreuer und bei
einem personalschlüssel von 1 120 für
die sozialdienste wie wollen wir bei
diesen schlechten personalschlüssel die
menschen mit behinderung in der wfbm
fördern damit sie den ersten schritt in
den arbeitsmarkt schaffen konnte
brauchen hier wesentliche verbesserungen
dann gelingt uns auf der schritt dass
die menschen mit behinderung aus der
wfbm in den ersten arbeitsmarkt können
und was wir aber auch brauchen ist mehr
begegnung ich habe ein unternehmen bei
mir im wahlkreis ich habe sie besucht
und habe dann irgendwann vier anlagen
gesehen die nicht verwendet werden hab
dann den geschäftsführer gefragt warum
werden die dann nicht benutzt da hat er
gesagt ich habe keine fachkräfte ich
habe nicht mal mitarbeiter jetzt habe
ich natürlich ein gekonntes auge dafür
und hab gesagt nein ich habe für sie
vier und habe daraufhin eben veranlasst
dass menschen aus meiner einrichtung aus
meiner ehemaligen einrichtungen dorthin
vermittelt werden das hat nur gezeigt
dass wir mehr begegnungen zwischen
wirtschaft und den wert bands brauchen
mehr begegnung zwischen den unternehmen
und den einrichtungen damit uns das
gelingt aber
ich möchte ihnen ja auch erzählen was
wir auch noch alles vorhaben durch die
einführung einer vierten stufe der
ausgleichsabgabe wird es für die
unternehmen teurer wer weniger macht
wird auch mehr zahlen müssen meine damen
und herren zweitens wir werden mit der
genehmigungs fiktion entlastung schaffen
gerade kleinere und mittlere unternehmen
von bürokratie befreien der vollständige
anträge auf begleitende unterstützung im
arbeitsleben stellt hat nach sechs
wochen sowieso die sicherheit der
genehmigung so oder so wer inklusion
schafft bekommt von uns freie fahrt und
noch ein aspekt der bei ihnen völlig
fehlt das betriebliche
eingliederungsmanagement
eingliederung in den arbeitsmarkt
bedeutet nämlich oft wiedereingliederung
mit verbindlichen und einheitlichen
qualitätsstandards sorgen wir hier für
die menschen in unserem land ich denke
auch im hinblick auf die longo witt
erkrankungen kann das ein wichtiger
präventiver faktor sein
was aber nicht besonders erst ist wir
werden ein ganzheitliches konzept
vorlegen nämlich ein bundesprogramm der
barrierefreiheit wir machen den abbau
von barrieren zur pflicht für alle vom
wohnen über digitales bis mobilität denn
wer im alltag weniger barrieren hat der
hat auch einen besseren schnelleren und
umfassenderen weg in die inklusive
arbeitswelt von morgen wichtig ist mir
aber auch dass wir auch an die barrieren
rangehen die in den einstellungen der
menschen sind nicht nur an die physische
barrieren daran gehen sondern auch an
die subjektiven barrieren rangehen und
damit auch die barrieren überwinden
können eines möchte ich aber dann doch
los werden
das ist ein persönliches anliegen von
mir ich denke wir müssen auch die
wissenschaftliche evaluation des bundes
teilhabe gesetzes auch parlamentarisch
begleiten das werde ich in den fokus
meiner arbeit setzen deshalb möchte ich
jetzt schon anraten das bundes
teilhabegesetz umzusetzen überall da wo
wir jetzt benötige und auch so schnell
wie möglich ich kann ihnen zusichern ich
kann ziemlich nervig werden wenn das uns
nicht gelingt deshalb bleiben sie
gespannt ja ich falls ich sehe das an
ihren augen dass ich jetzt schon nervig
bin und dementsprechend schmerz und
glück auf
damit kommen wir zum nächsten redner
wenn hier das pult es infiziert wurde
das ist hannes genau aus der hfg
fraktion
jetzt bricht hannes genau für die armee
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
wir haben es bei diesem antrag der cdu
mit einem wichtigen und prägenden
anliegen zu tun die arbeitslosigkeit von
menschen mit behinderung zu reduzieren
die dazu notwendigen rahmenbedingungen
auszugleichen und eine allgemeine lebens
verbesserung für unsere mitbürger zu
erwirken ist absolut notwendig doch
leider konterkarieren sie auf anderer
ebene alle bemühungen und pläne aus
diesem antrag und zwar mit der von ihnen
verabschiedeten einrichtungs bezogenen
impfpflicht werte kollegen der parteien
sie können sich nicht für eine bessere
einbindung von menschen mit behinderung
in unserer gesellschaft einsetzen wenn
sie zeitgleich das dafür notwendige
personal aus ihren beruf verbannen und
das obwohl bereits jetzt an akutem
fachkräftemangel
leiden sie werden sie werden das leben
von vielen mitbürgern mit behinderungen
massiv verschlechtern ja mit den worten
einer 57 jährigen aus niedersachsen die
impfpflicht für pfleger zerstört mein
leben und die betroffene dame kümmerten
sich bisher vier pfleger in
verschiedenen blog diensten dieses
modell droht nun zu zerfallen und damit
ihre lebensqualität überhaupt fachkräfte
zu finden die für den lohn zu diesen
bedingungen arbeiten ist bereits eine
riesige herausforderung auch ohne
impfpflicht und angesichts der aussage
des gesundheitsministers lauterbach
wonach bloß der eine oder andere
radikale impfgegner aus seinem job
aussteigen müsse muss man hier wohl
feststellen der homöopathischen corona
mainstream politik von links bis union
ist das schicksal unserer behinderten
mitbürger sowie die ungeimpften pfleger
offenbar egal der chef der chef des
caritas verbands wolfgang thier ich da
sieht hier eine gefährdung der
versorgungsqualität und sicherheit für
menschen mit behinderungen die
mitarbeiter im sozial und
gesundheitswesen stehen als fachkräfte
schließlich in einem engen
vertrauensverhältnis zu ihren patienten
sie lassen sich nicht einfach so
austauschen und die bindung zwischen
menschen mit behinderung und ihren
betreuern meine damen und herren ist
doch so viel mehr als nur ein kaltes
dienst leistungsverhältnis
ulrich schneider der
hauptgeschäftsführer des paritätischen
gesamtverbandes mahnt dass mit dieser
impfpflicht regional massive personal
und versorgungsengpässe drohen und mehr
noch er bezeichnet diese von ihnen
verhängte impfpflicht als gesetz gegen
den operativen sachverstand und recht
hat der mann
meine damen und herren vor mit cdu sie
können jede notwendigen maßnahmen
fordern um die soziale lage von menschen
mit behinderung in unserem land zu
verbessern doch solange sie einen
endlich politik unterstützen welche die
bestehende versorgungslage zu zerstören
droht kann man ihre forderungen nur als
eigenes bezeichnen billige heuchelei
ihre ehemalige kanzlerin merkel
bezeichnete ihr verständnis von
christdemokratischer politik einst als
mal liberal mal konservativ und mal
christlich sozial letzteres war stets
geheuchelt der konservatismus und das
wissen sie eine lüge und ersteres immer
zur falschen zeit und während ihre ikone
in der migrationspolitik zur mutti
merkel hoch geschrieben wurde wurden
menschen mit behinderungen
stiefmütterlich behandelt mit dem
drohenden quasi arbeitsverbot für viele
wichtige betreuer durch ihren impfzwang
riskieren sie nur den zusammenbruch der
versorgung dass meine herren von denen
meine damen und herren von den parteien
haben sie alle zu verantworten denn hier
macht die schein oppositionelle mit der
linksliberalen regierungen gemeinsame
sache sie riskieren mit ihrer politik
eine regelrechte soziale krise und das
obwohl in allen ländern um uns herum die
krone maßnahmen aufgehoben werden und
selbst in österreich die irrsinnige
impfpflicht gekippt wurde deshalb
stellen sie ihren unsinnigen impfzwang
zurück und geben sie so mit einer
verbesserung für die teilhabe unserer
mit menschen mit behinderung überhaupt
erst eine chance dass meine damen und
herren wir dann tatsächlich mal
solidarisch vielen dank
[Applaus]
jetzt spricht corinna rüffer für bündnis
90 die grünen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
demokratinnen und demokraten
die afg hat mal gerade wieder unter
beweis gestellt dass ihnen das leben
behinderter menschen ehrlich gesagt
sonst wo vorbei gibt sie haben keinen
einzigen satz jetzt zu diesem antrag und
zum thema beigetragen die einrichtungs
bezogen die impfpflicht heißt mit der
hat mit der inklusiven beschäftigung
wieder von menschen überhaupt seien
schlicht und ergreifend steht mir
einfach leid dass sie hier so die
redezeit verschwenden der unterschied
zwischen ihnen und der ehemaligen
kanzlerin angela merkel ist das möchte
an der stelle auch noch mal sagen dass
sie den hauch eines verständnisses
gehabt hat von diesem thema sie hat sich
verabschiedet nämlich dabei sehr
überrascht dass sie das nach all den
vielen jahren dann doch mal endlich tut
als eine frau die auf dem gelände einer
behinderteneinrichtung in der ddr
aufgewachsen ist dass man dieser
einrichtung aufzulösen hat und dass man
kindern von anfang an die möglichkeit
geben muss mit allen anderen kindern
zusammen inklusiv beschult zu werden und
dass menschen den werkstätten arbeiten
ein anrecht haben auf einen anständigen
lohn und den die möglichkeit zum zugangs
wagen die inklusiven arbeitsmarkt und
deswegen weil es einer branche
beigetragen haben und er möchte ich
sagen
dass man an manchen stellen wirklich
deutlich merkt dass es gut ist wenn in
einem land nicht immer die gleichen am
ruder sitzen und nach 16 jahren war es
ehrlich gesagt auch wirklich an der zeit
dass die cdu jetzt mal und die
unionsfraktionen auf der oppositionsbank
sitzen und ich möchte ihnen sagen dass
meine ich überhaupt nicht böse sondern
zu einer guten demokratie gehört es dazu
dass mal luft rein gelassen wird und das
merkt man ein bisschen an ihrem antrag
und außerdem finde ich es total gut wenn
in einem parlamenten möglichst viele
menschen sitzen die einen hauch davon
haben was das bedeutet an einer
inklusiven gesellschaft zur arbeit
nämlich lebensqualität und fortschritt
für alle menschen und ich glaube dass
mit hubert hüppe der da in der ersten
reihe sitzt jemand neue wieder neu im
bundestag ist ja eine vorstellung davon
hat und ich bin mir ziemlich sicher dass
hubert hüppe an diesem antrag auf jeden
fall mitgearbeitet hat er es nicht
perfekt aber er ist nicht schlecht ist
es einiges abgeschrieben von uns und
vielleicht auch von anderen da bin ich
mir nicht so sicher aber es ist auf
jeden fall eine gute grundlage auf der
man diskutieren kann aber andererseits
muss ich ihnen sagen das mir bildlich
die tränen kommen wenn ich darüber
nachdenke
was wir in den vergangenen jahren hätten
gemeinsam zustande bringen können wenn
wir uns in diesem hohen haus zusammen
getan hätten um ernst zu machen mit der
vollen und gleichberechtigten teilhabe
von menschen mit behinderungen wenn wir
unsere kraft darauf gerichtet hätten
strukturen zu schaffen die tatsächlich
für alle zugänglich sind und die auch
funktionieren
stattdessen ich zitiere noch nie waren
so viele menschen mit behinderungen in
sondereinrichtungen die aussonderung
strukturen haben sich durchgesetzt die
inklusion ist auf dem rückmarsch
sonderschulen werden zum teil mit
enormen finanz und personalaufwand
erweitert oder gar neu gebaut die
schulische inklusion wird kaputt gespart
in der folge steigt auf die zahl von
menschen in werkstätten es werden
milliarden
die explosion gesteckt und in der
wohlfahrt in dustrie wird immer mehr
geld hätten so steht es geschrieben auf
der website unseres ehemaligen
behindertenbeauftragte hubert hüppe und
er hat recht mit dem was er sagt nur
leider das was er sagte mit der politik
der union
bisher überhaupt gar nichts zu tun
gehabt wie oft habe ich mir anhören
müssen dass förderschulen das
werkstätten und heime schon gut sein für
die behinderten die menschen wollten den
werkstätten arbeiten weil sie den
schutzraum feuchten und sich dort wohl
fühlten aber die realität sehr verehrte
damen und herren ist doch oftmals eine
andere ich möchte mal aus einem
interview mit frauen nennen wir sie
schmitz zitieren die heute das möchte
ich vorweg schicken beim unternehmen
fest angestellt ist sie hatte keinen
schulabschluss ist irgendwann wie sie
sagt in einer massiven depression
gelandet und deshalb nicht mehr vor die
tür gegangen frau schmidt hat glück
gehabt über ein praktikum bekam sie die
gelegenheit und betreute arbeiten formal
formuliert in einen betriebs
integrierten arbeitsplatz einzusteigen
und sie sagt ich zitiere dadurch hatte
ich die möglichkeit sanft und ohne druck
wieder oder überhaupt in arbeit
einzusteigen man ist offiziell bei einer
werkstatt für menschen mit behinderungen
angemeldet aber arbeitet nicht dort
sondern in einem ganz normalen
unternehmen das heißt man ist nicht auf
dem ersten arbeitsmarkt und muss nicht
die verantwortung und leistung bringen
die damit einhergeht ich habe damals mit
einer reduzierten stundenzahl angefangen
und mich dann langsam aber stetig
gesteigert bis sich bei der vollzeit
angekommen bin ich konnte an der zeit
eingearbeitet werden ohne dass es schon
leistung bringen musste ich war als
helfende hand dabei damit ich überhaupt
in dem unternehmen anfangen konnte
musste ich mir als erstes eine sbm eine
behindertenwerkstatt anschauen dabei
habe ich festgestellt dass ich nie
wieder arbeiten möchte ich hatte das
gefühl wenn ich vorher nicht schon
behindert denn dann bestimmt nachdem ich
dort arbeiten musste ohne die
möglichkeit eines betriebs integrierten
arbeitsplatzes wäre ich diesen weg nicht
gegangen und heute wahrscheinlich noch
immer stark depressiv und vor allen
dingen auch arbeitslos für mich war es
genau der richtige weg um stabil genug
zu werden damit ich meine ausbildung
beginnen kann frau schmidt hat es
geschafft weil sie das glück hatte
unterstützung auf ihrem individuellen
weg wird zu bekommen viele andere
menschen haben dieses glück nicht glück
darf aber keine kategorie sein wenn es
darum geht geltendes recht in anspruch
zu nehmen und ihre liegt denn auch die
kernaufgabe für die kommenden jahre wir
müssen es schaffen den bürokratie
dschungel zu lichten wir brauchen ein
service start und keinen kafka start
lassen sie uns diesen weg gemeinsam
gehen als demokraten innerhalb dieses
parlamentes und ernsthaft an einer
inklusiven gesellschaft
arbeiten ich bedanke mich
[Applaus]
corinna rüffer gerade hier in der
debatte zu einem antrag der
unionsfraktion der nach dieser debatte
dann zur weiteren beratung an die
entsprechenden ausschüsse überwiesen
wird federführend ist der ausschuss für
arbeit und soziales
syrien pellmann spricht jetzt erst der
sprecher für inklusion und teilhabe der
linksfraktion
herzlich willkommen mit der realen welt
der menschen mit behinderung eines muss
man ihnen lassen humor haben sie der
antrag den sie auch vorlegen könnte man
als satire oder doch eher als selbst
abrechnung verstehen ich habe schon in
ihrer reingeguckt ob jetzt vielleicht
gleich jan böhmermann in ihren reihen
auftaucht und als neuer abgeordneter bei
ihnen um die ecke kommt
muss hier im plenum erst ich muss heute
hier um erstmals von einer erleuchtung
sprechen im feststellung style liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen haben sie
nämlich vieles richtig analysiert
menschen mit behinderungen sind länger
und häufiger arbeitslos es sind zu
wenige unternehmerinnen und unternehmen
die ihre verantwortung für inklusion
ernst nehmen sie stellen zu wenige
menschen mit schwerbehinderung 1
25% bzw 40.000 unternehmerinnen und
unternehmer sind sogenannte null
beschäftigung sie beschäftigen trotz
ihrer pflicht keinen einzigen menschen
mit schwerbehinderung hier drängt sich
mir zumindest regelrecht die frage auf
warum ist das so
es gibt eine sehr einfache antwort das
ist die bilanz ihrer 16-jährigen
regierungsverantwortung die durch
versagen geprägt war
16 jahre kanzlerschaft merkel und 16
jahre ignorieren der realitäten wollen
sie mit einem völlig verkürzen antrag
nun mehr reparieren 16 jahre tiefschlaf
und jetzt wachen sie endlich auf
bestes beispiel bestes beispiel die
aufhebung der deckelung des budgets für
arbeit wer hat denn diesen deckel dafür
auf und wollte ihn unbedingt haben das
waren sie als unionsfraktion die
wahrnehmungsveränderungen hätten sie
nach meiner auffassung viel früher
erfolgen müssen
zur erinnerung liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen sie hatten so eine chance dazu
wir hatten am 22 april 20 21 ein sehr
umfangreichen antrag vorgelegt wo es
schon gute arbeit für menschen mit
behinderung gibt ihre fraktion hat
damals mit nein gestimmt darin sieben
seiten wirkliche reform für einen
inklusiven arbeitsmarkt bessere beratung
und vermittlung
deutliche anhebung der ausgleichsabgabe
stärkung und ausweitung der inklusions
betriebe stärkung der selbstvertretung
und mitbestimmung von menschen mit
behinderung
inklusive ausrichtung und neuaufstellung
der finanzierung der werkstätten
einführung des mindestlohns und
hungerlöhne zwischen ein und zwei euro
pro stunde endlich zu beenden auch
ordentliche löhne für menschen mit
behinderungen sind eine form der
anerkennung ihrer täglichen arbeit
was bleibt nun die erkenntnis dass 16
jahre lang viel zu wenig für diese
bevölkerungsgruppe getan wurde
allerdings die befürchtung darauf deuten
zumindest bisherige ankündigung der
neuen regierungskoalition hin genannt
sei sie haben das sehr eindrucksvoll
gesagt die einführung der vierten stufe
für 0 beschäftigung dass auch hier aus
taten folgen müssen und nicht nur leere
ankündigung
um so wichtiger liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen da haben sie uns natürlich dann
lehrerseite umso wichtiger ist es dass
wir als linke gemeinsam mit ihnen für
einen echten inklusiven arbeitsmarkt
weiter kämpfen vielen dank
der kollege jens beeck hat das board für
die fdp-fraktion
und gut ist total habe politische
sprecher seiner fraktion
[Applaus]
hoch verehrte frau präsidentin meine
sehr geschätzten kolleginnen und
kollegen lieber herr kollege los und da
meine ich so wie ich es sagen nachdem
wir jetzt
über vier jahre in unterschiedlichen
konstellationen an einem thema arbeiten
haben sie mich so ganz oft nicht
überrascht aber mit dem ding haben es
geschafft die ihn habe ich nicht kommen
sehen ich habe auf meinem schreibtisch
liegen gehabt und habe gedacht das ja
deiner
oma total überrascht als ich am ende des
antrags gelesen habe felix märz und
andere da wusste ich das ist gar nicht
mein asmus ihrer sein das ist aber schon
erstaunlich dass aber schon erstaunlich
weil der antrag das will ich ihnen
ausdrücklich sagen ist nicht nur im
analyse teil gut er hat auch an vielen
stellen gute und richtige ansätze in
ihren forderungen unter ziffer 2 und
bisschen überrascht war ich war mir die
eine oder andere formulierung richtig
bekannt vorkam und von den 20 punkten
die sie aufführen
ist einer nämlich die ziffer 20 ein
aufruf zur öffentlichkeitsarbeit das
eigentlich jetzt nach 16 jahren
regierungsverantwortung nicht so richtig
toll die punkte 15 und 17 würde ich
ihnen ausdrücklich sagen wir haben sie
gute punkte und ich freue mich auch die
beratung im ausschuss da werden wir
gemeinschaftlichen stück weiter kommen
und
alles andere haben sie entweder eins zu
eins bei der ziffer 5 wortwörtlich aus
drucksachen des bundestages und anträgen
der fdp-bundestagsfraktion abgeschrieben
oder aus dem koalitionsvertrag
oder sie haben es selber bei eigenen
gesetzes projekten die noch keine zwölf
monate zurückliegen in diesem haus als
sie noch regierung waren aktiv
versammelt ich habe ihnen das mal
gastiert das weiß er ist das gute das
boote haben sie entweder aktiv als er
mit oder zum teil wie gesagt in der
ziffer 5 wortwörtlich aus einer
bundestags drucksache aus einem antrag
der fdp abgeschrieben das heißt jetzt
nicht dass alles schlecht ist aber ich
will es mal kurz durch gehen ich habe
heute wird sagen wir fünf minuten ziffer
1 original übernommen aus dem
koalitionsvertrag nett dass sie sagen
der ist gut finden wir auch ziffer 2
fdp forderung der 19 wahlperiode
verankert im koalitionsvertrag mit den
jetzigen partner ziffer 3 fdp forderung
aus der 19 wahlperiode uns immer von
ihnen abgelehnt jetzt verankert im
koalitionsvertrag ziffer 4 damit ein
bisschen knifflig da geht es um die
umsatzsteuer privilegierung der
inklusions unternehmen da haben wir in
der letzten wahlperiode beantragt das
thema räumen wir ab weil sich der zwei
senate beim bundesfinanzhof streiten
aber wir uns einig sind dass das eine
sehr angemessene privilegierung
umsatzsteuerrecht ist haben beantragt
und das werden wir auch machen steht
nämlich jetzt auch im koalitionsvertrag
formell zu privilegieren im paragrafen
12 umsatzsteuergesetz sie bleiben mit
der richtigen analyse bei uns mit ihrem
lösungsvorschlag ich guck mal ob er an
europa irgendwann eben eine klarstellung
hinkriegen weit hinter dem zurück was
erforderlich ist also an der stelle ist
der antrag nicht so gut aber wenigstens
haben sie erkannt ziffer 5 ist der teil
den sie aus der ich sag's ihnen auch
gerne drucksache 19 strich 8 10 257
wortwörtlich abgeschrieben haben finde
ich deswegen gut habe ich ja damals
schon gut gefunden das ist eingebracht
hat 6 ist ein guter punkt könnte danach
gucken das können sie unter bundestag.de
drucksachen das finden sich alles
guter punkt die sechs und auch die
sieben rappen sie machen sollen als sie
die entsprechenden gesetze vor weniger
als zwölf monaten angefasst haben das
gleiche gilt für die punkte ja wie denn
indem sie unseren anträgen
änderungsanträgen folge oder indem sie
einfach alles richtig gemacht hätten
haben sie aber nicht weil sie auch nicht
wollte andere wollten ja vielleicht
damals so war sie aber damals nicht
deswegen finde ich es auch wirklich gut
dass sie in die familie derer
zurückkommen die sehr ernsthaft
inklusions politik in diesem hause
betrachten wir freuen uns darauf dass
mit ihnen zu machen ich will ihnen das
ganz schnell noch mal ich hab ja immer
noch 58 sekunden früher war das viel
weniger wahrscheinlich habe gut
abgeschnitten zu recht bei der
bundestagswahl ziffer 9 fdp-antrag
mehrfach von ihnen abgelehnt ziffer 10
fdp antrag von ihnen abgelehnten 11 12
13 und 14
hätten sie bei der novellierung der
entsprechenden gesetze lockermachen
können wir hatten auch darüber
gesprochen 15 damit gesagt er super 16
sie haben bürokratiemonster geschaffen
in den letzten 16 jahren übrigens nicht
nur im bereich des sgb 9 sondern im
gesamten deutschen sozialstaat wir sind
beide anwälte wir haben beide im
sozialrecht gearbeitet auch wir können
heute nicht mehr in eine aktive gucken
und sofort wissen was richtig ist oder
müssen uns darauf richtig vorbereiten
dagegen gegen diese chemie ihren die sie
aufgebaut haben wird diese ampel
koalition kämpfen diesen monstern
stellen die uns entgegen und wir kommen
zu echten übrigens auch im
koalitionsvertrag bereits verankert zu
echten verbesserungen auch im bereich
der bürokratie im ergebnis ich freue
mich auf die beratung kopie ist
angeblich die höchste form der
anerkennung deswegen herzlichen dank für
ihre anerkennung der arbeit der fdp
fraktion aus der letzten wahl
im koalitionsvertrag ist dieser ampel
freue mich sehr darauf wertegemeinschaft
ich diese themen nach vorne bringen
jens baganz hat muss jedoch das sind
alles erhält dank für die anerkennung
der union darauf reagieren kann nun
hubert hüppe aus der unionsfraktion er
war
2010 20 14 beauftragter der
bundesregierung für die belange
behinderter menschen
unserem antrag zustimmen das habe ich
jetzt ihren worten
und ich wundere mich allerdings etwas
über herrn mehmet ali der so tut als sei
die spd gar nicht in der regierung
gewesen und das ministerium sei gar kein
spd ministerium gewesen aus denen
eigentlich die ganzen formulierungen die
wir angreifen wir auch stamm meine damen
und herren und noch mal vorweg natürlich
natürlich hierhin wir nicht den anspruch
alle wege hier aufzuzeigen die zu mehr
inklusion am ersten arbeitsmarkt führen
aber wir haben eben ein paar punkte mehr
dante uns wichtig sind und die dazu
beitragen können dass menschen gerade
auch junge menschen eher in den
arbeitsmarkt kommen auch wenn sie eine
behinderung kam und ich nenne ihnen ein
wichtiges beispiel ich nenne mal die
werke um fachpraktika ausbildung nach §
42 handwerksordnung oder 66
berufsbildungs ordnung das sind die
ausbildung für menschen die eine
vollausbildung nicht schaffen und die
aufgrund ihrer behinderung oft auch
ihrer lernbehinderung dann eine
reduzierte ausbildung machen können
meistens im berufsbildungswerken in
einrichtungen wie winter einrichtungs
vertreter und
man kann es auch im ersten arbeitsmarkt
machen aber sie können es nur dann im
ersten arbeitsmarkt machen wenn der
ausbilder eine rehabilitations
pädagogische zusatzqualifikation für
ausbilderinnen und ausbildern macht und
diese
qualifikation kurz genannt bedeutet dass
der ausbilder 3
die stunden sich fortbilden lassen muss
in recht in didaktik und in medizin
meine damen und herren wie sieht das
denn in wirklichkeit aus da kommt der
geselle zu seinem meister und sagt du
kannst du auch meine tochter die hat bei
dir praktikum gemacht die ist ehrlich
fleißig kommt pünktlich feiert nie krank
kannst dich nicht ausbilden das macht er
meister klar aber die schafft doch die
berufsschule nicht da sagt der sender
habe ich gehört da gibt es aber so der
handwerksordnung da geht es doch ja sagt
er denn dazu ist macht was man sagt der
meister da muss ich dir aber sagen du
musst dich jetzt noch 320 stunden
fortbildung in didaktik medizin und in
recht meine damen und herren das macht
kein kleiner betrieb und diese
bürokratie wollen wir abbauen deswegen
sagen wir in unserem antrag die gräser
muss freiwillig sein sie muss gestrafft
werden und die kosten darf nicht der
betrieb bezahlen müssen sondern das muss
der staat machen meine damen und herren
und deswegen
herweg haben wir auch gesagt dass er die
bürokratie abbauen übrigens der antrag
stammt bestimmt nicht von ihnen die
nicht gerade gesagt hat dieser punkt wir
wollen auf jeden fall bürokratie abbauen
wir wollen dass es budgets in allen
bereichen auch der ausbildung für
menschen mit behinderungen geht auch in
den bereichen des berufsbildungsbereich
des eingangsbereichs dann lass uns das
doch endlich machen natürlich gibt es in
vielen bereichen auch schon den
rechtlichen anspruch darauf aber meine
damen und herren vor ort ist das nicht
bekannt und es wird werden angeboten und
natürlich wollen wir auch dass mehr
menschen erschaffen von der werkstatt in
den ersten arbeitsmarkt zu bekommen aber
dann müssen wir tatsächlich
zum beispiel das budget für ausbildung
neu fassen sie können nicht rein sie
bekommen ein budget für ausbildung wenn
sie anspruch auf werkstattleistungen
haben und sie einen vertrag vorweisen
für eine vollausbildung oder eine werke
meine damen und herren wer eine
vollausbildung macht der behördlichen
werkstatt und hat deswegen auch kein
anspruch auf diese leistungen und
deswegen ist es natürlich nicht gar
nicht ist das ja auch verständlich dass
wir deswegen nur 31 budgets für für
ausbildung in ganz deutschland in über
20 monaten haben und das müssen wir
ändern und nicht sehr gut es wäre gut
wenn sie damit machen machen sie mit und
wir bieten ihnen das an es gibt den
spruch
wer
es gibt den spruch wer inklusion will
sucht wege wären sie nicht besucht
begründung wir haben ihnen ein paar wege
aufgezeigt und es würde mich freuen wenn
sie ein paar wege hin zu vielen dank
damit kann herziehen letzten rednerin um
diese debatte das ist angelika glöckner
sie sitzt für die sozialdemokraten im
ausschuss für arbeit und soziales des
bundestags
[Applaus]
kolleginnen und kollegen
ich fange mal so an 13 jahre endlich in
der preis konvention das zeugt davon
dass es sich auch in der in der
behindertenpolitik etwas entwickelt hat
ich will aber auch klar und deutlich
sagen wir haben noch einen weiten weg
vor uns und das gilt natürlich auch
insbesondere mit blick auf den
arbeitsmarkt denn noch immer sind es die
menschen mit behinderungen die es
schwieriger haben und für die es schwer
ist den eintritt in den arbeitsmarkt zu
finden im vergleich zu ihren
nichtbehinderten fachkräften kolleginnen
und kollegen woran es liegt dass wissen
wir es wurde bereits mehrfach
angesprochen beispielsweise weil
unternehmen menschen mit behinderung
nicht einstellen wollen weil sie sie
nicht beschäftigen wollen oder auch weil
der weg für die werkstattbeschäftigten
aus der werkstatt heraus einfach nicht
durchlässig genug ist oder aber auch
manchmal an ganz anderen themen waren
menschen mit behinderungen
mobilitätsprobleme haben weil sie nicht
wissen wie sie von ihrem von ihrem
zuhause auf die arbeit kommen und
vielleicht auch wieder zurück und das
alles ein bunter strauß an wichtigen
themen und wichtigen fragen das nehmen
wir sozialdemokratinnen und
sozialdemokraten sehr ernst und ich sage
inklusion wird nur gelingen wenn wir
diese wichtigen sozialen fragen auch
wirklich anpacken und dafür machen wir
von der spd uns stark
was also
können wir konkret tun ja wir wollen die
beratungsstellen für die unternehmen
noch mehr ausbauen für noch bessere
beratungsangebote und die instrumente
budget für arbeit und budget für
ausbildung auch die müssen
weiterentwickelt werden eben damit die
werkstätten durchlässiger werden hin zum
ersten arbeitsmarkt
und wir wollen auch dass die das
zusammenspiel zwischen den werkstätten
und zwischen den inklusions unternehmen
aber auch zwischen den sogenannten
anderen leistungsanbietern befördert
wird und das ganz wichtig gesagt wurde
auch von meinen kollegen tag ich alles
mit dass wir eben darauf hinwirken dass
menschen die im arbeitsprozess stehen
ihre arbeit behalten da sie eben nicht
aus dem arbeitsmarkt herausfliegen und
deswegen die es ist total wichtig dass
wir solche instrumente wie das
betriebliche eingliederungsmanagement
breiter fekter auf verbindlicher stärken
und etablieren kolleginnen und kollegen
auch das wurde schon gesagt arbeit
ermöglicht soziale kontakte arbeit
befördert wertschätzung und arbeit
ermöglicht es dass menschen mit
behinderung ihr eigenes geld verdienen
können und damit auch ihr leben
selbstbestimmt in die hand nehmen können
das ist total wichtig und genau da
müssen wir ansetzen diese punkte müssen
wir umgehend in angriff nehmen und ich
sage aber an der stelle auch ganz klar
erfolgreiche inklusions politik geht
gibt es nicht zum nulltarif und deswegen
sage ich auch
peter aktion eine solide finanzierung
all diese vorhaben hat von uns höchste
priorität
werde kolleginnen und kollegen von der
union sie legen uns heute einen antrag
vor mit vorschlägen für mehr inklusion
in den arbeitsmarkt und ich nehme es
vorweg ihr antrag überzeugt nicht und
ich will ist auch an zwei zentralen
punkten festmachen warum das so ist
erstens sie wollen dass die werkstatt
löhne für ein vorläufiges entgeltpunkte
bekommen und ich muss ehrlich sagen das
verwundert mich sicher sie haben doch
selbst in der letzten wahlperiode dafür
zugestimmt dass wir begleitend mit einer
wissenschaftlichen expertise uns
unterschiedliche entgelt modelle
anschauen und auf basis dieser expertise
dann uns überlegen gemeinsam mit
menschen mit behinderungen welches
entgelt mutter wir wählen das entgelt
modell muss transparent und auch
auskömmlich sein und was sie jetzt
machen ist ein zwischen modell das dazu
führt dass wir mehr bürokratie aufwand
bei den werkstätten haben dass die
menschen keine transparente entgelt
systeme kommt sondern eher verwirrt
werden das ist das gegenteil dessen was
wir wollen 2 sie wollen dass der bund
seinen anteil an der ausgleichsabgabe
abgibt sie wissen doch aber ganz genau
dass wir damit wichtige überregionale
projekte fördern eben um inklusion in
den arbeitsmarkt zu verbessern und was
sie überhaupt nicht erwähnen ist dass es
firmen gibt die nach wie vor nicht
bereit sind bei allen hilfsangeboten
menschen mit behinderungen zu
beschäftigen und ich sage hier ganz klar
es wird zeit dass wir endlich eine
vierte stufe für die ausgleichsabgabe
verbindlich einführen und ich bin sehr
froh dass es uns gelungen ist mit den
neuen koalitionspartners zu vereinbaren
mit ihnen war das leider nicht möglich
dass ich dies abschließend auch noch mal
einer sagen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wir leben in herausfordernden
zeiten und es ist total wichtig dass wir
auch zeigen unsere demokratie ist stark
wir fördern inklusion und damit fördern
wir elefant und das ist das gegenteil
von autokratie und von unterwürfigkeit
und von unterdrückung und deshalb lassen
sie uns gemeinsam anpacken vielen dank
das war die debatte hier zum inklusiven
arbeitsmarkt zur inklusiven arbeitswelt
aufgrund eines antrags der
unionsfraktion allerdings wird dieser
antrag nun erst einmal in die
entsprechenden ausschüsse überwiesen
dort weiter beraten und dann auch wieder
hier im plenum zur debatte gebracht
werden also das thema wird uns weiter
verfolgen wir verabschieden uns für
heute aus dem deutschen bundestag sind
aber natürlich morgen wieder da ab 8 uhr
45 mit einem interview und dann
natürlich mit übertragung unter anderem
geht ist ja dann um die gesetze zur
impfpflicht und die korona maßnahmen
werden thema sein
aber natürlich auch wieder die
internationale lage und die lage der
geflüchteten die nach deutschland kommen
möchten bis dahin also auf wiedersehen
ich bitte diejenigen die uns
bedauerlicherweise verlassen wollen oder
müssen dass zügig zu tun und ansonsten
platz zu nehmen
[Musik]